um unfortunately the senate has session
today so we're um
going to be in a position where senators
probably will not be here to present
their bills so i might ask some of you
to just introduce the bills and then we
can allow
members of the public that are going to
be speaking for and against so at least
we can start this
and then we have an exec session
next wednesday on these four bills we
may i'll explain the first bill in a
moment here what the situation is
we have a pretty simple bill from
representative from senator d'alessandro
senate bill 276 and there's been an
amendment which i emailed to you from
representative from senator gaida
so we're going to kind of explain what's
going on and what our options are here
as a committee all right i'd like to
introduce representative
i'm sorry oh sorry i'm getting ahead of
myself mr clark would you please call
the roll
infantine yes here
seaworth avalani
callum
myself yeah love
warden
turcotte
sullivan
susie
rudy
cahill here
lisa vestro
schmidt here to me yeah bouchard here
hesitant yeah
mandeville yeah
thank you
but open the hearing on senate bill 276
and i recognize representative abrami
thank you mr chair uh for the record
state rep pattabrami rockingham 19
and i'm also vice chair of ways and
means which is relevant to this
discussion
and also chair the tax expenditure
review committee a joint committee with
the senate and it's also relevant to
this discussion
so
let's
first talk about the uh
army
advanced regenerative manufacturing
institute
army we we passed a bill four years ago
that gave tax breaks
to businesses well let me explain what
army is
army is is uh
um
received a for a 60 million dollar grant
dean cayman
received a 60 million dollar grant
from the department of defense to
develop
uh and to bring to market
manufacture
body parts body organs like kidneys
the thought then was that all the
science is there it's in every basement
of every academic medical center
around the country
was to create this ecosystem
where he was able to
would be able to attract businesses
1g2z businesses with phds that
specialize in a little piece of this a
little piece of that bring them together
to
the milliard
where he has his his facilities
now that was four years ago
and uh so we we we passed the bill and
there was two components of the bill
one was
10-year
tax breaks
for any business that came
he said
the reason why he came to the
legislature to ask for this is that
after he got that 16 million dollar
uh grant
every state came after him saying
don't do it in new hampshire come to us
they made him big offers to move out of
the state move this out of the state
and he loves new hampshire he didn't
want to move he said to the state you
got to help us
and he asked for two things he asked for
some tax breaks for these small
companies moving in
uh 10 years now so if a company moves in
doing this stuff
so now we're four years in so if a
company moves in now
that'll be six years of tax breaks okay
now this is something we don't do very
often to give tax breaks but we we we
did this
the second part was he asked for tuition
forgiveness
to for these people coming in
and that was to be managed by the new
hampshire
business finance authority
and we we created a um
we created a
uh
i gotta get my glasses here
it's called the state regenerative
manufacturing workforce development fund
so
so that's the big that's the big picture
so now we're four years in
senator d'alessandro
and in the fall
uh presented the underlying bell which
you have
in in the original
language of the bill that was of the of
the bill that we passed four years ago
it said that
that the the authority
business the new hampshire fund business
finance authority was supposed to report
annually to the fiscal committee
now for four years and representative
romney will attest to this as well
we haven't seen anything from anybody
with a matter of fact we've been asking
questions i wonder how i wonder how
army's doing
uh
so so but senator d'alessandro who's on
on uh ways and means in in
in the senate
put a an amendment in or a bill in to
say let's also report to house ways and
means and senate ways of means
and that it said report every six months
so he put specific dates september first
and march first
which weighs the means
we want that and so uh well for the
committee yes
definitely pass the underlying bill
it just it just provides us the
information that we've been looking for
for the last four years so let me put my
other hat on now
so just a week i'm chair of the of the
um
tax expenditure review committee what
does that do
we have like seven
tax credits that we give
let's give let me give you an example
community development finance authority
new investment tax credit economic
revitalization dome tax credit research
and development tax credit cars county
job creation tax cut education tax
credit career and technical career
center tax credit and now exemption for
qualified regenerative manufacturing
companies so that's seven of them
so what this this little committee does
is just me uh representative ames and
senator geider
are on this review committee every two
years we look at all these credits to
see what's going on who's using them how
much money is being spent
and making the decision whether whether
these credits should continue and make
recommendations
so yeah so we finally got around to army
and
last
two weeks and a half ago we had one of
these meetings
and
james we had james key wallace from the
business finance authority come and
testify
and as well as maureen tui from army
so he went first
he said okay how are we doing with the
with the education
tuition part
and he he he testified that
um well we got the rules done we got
everything done that's okay
so so how much has gone out so far
nothing
and you go and i said why well we
haven't funded it
so there's no funding in it so the
amendment and then i looked to my right
i looked at senator guide and i said is
that news to you he goes yes i looked
to representative ames is that who's to
you yes
no one no one took care of the funding
part
so
senator goddard said i'll take care of
it and he
he
developed this amendment that's before
you well not before it was emailed to
you
asking for a million dollars to go into
this fund
now
was this the right bill to to have it go
uh
it it's it relates because it really is
an army bill
but
i talked to karen uh the chair of
finance representative romberger
and she says now put it on put it on
house bill senate bill another senate
bill and we'll make sure it gets
there in agreement with the million
dollars by the way in finance
but
but here we are with with the bill and
and i think i talked to karen berger
just this morning again
and she says no go ahead and go ahead
and pass it we'll make sure it somehow
winds up in finance
uh that they can bless it because this
is not an fn bill
uh and and she said she'd be talking to
the um
she'd be talking to the uh uh speaker
making sure that it does go to a second
committee to to be approved so
so i ask you to approve the underlying
bill and i also ask that you
uh approve the the million-dollar um
appropriation and that's my testimony
i'll take questions if there are any
thank you representative representative
cahill
good morning uh my friend from stratham
yep
um
could you tell me if there's been any
inquiries about the tuition have there
been people applying for it and being
said totally there's no money
well that's when uh
when the executive director of the army
came um maureen was next on that in that
committee who spoke i asked that
question
i i have a feeling they haven't done a
very good job of of advertising that
fact
which
but but then she talked about the fact
that they they just are completing
another 25 000 square feet of
manufacturing space
and that they are continuing to recruit
they are continuing to try to recruit
others to come
that this would be helpful if we did
fund this so
so we agreed so let's try to fund this
representative wharton
you have a follow-up representative
caleb follow up and then representative
uh
in the event that uh there are no takers
can we put the money someplace else
yes that's what happens with
in ways it means we have
what they call a dedicated fund review
committee that works
um actually representative valmi's on
this with uh with representative major
and a few others from the senate and
others
uh so we we look every
you know we there's a lot of dedicated
funds actually there's 300 dedicated
funds
so they need to be monitored
to say okay is this fund dead is this
what's going on and we we monitor
i'm sure they'll put this one on the
list in a couple of years just to see if
that money then and then we actually do
we have that we form a bill
uh that you may may not because usually
it's unanimous generally on consent
calendar so you guys don't see this but
that we do we do say close down this
fund
we say
any money left in that fund go back to
the general fund or wherever generally
the general fund so we do we do track
that
representative warden thank you
just as a clarification on that tax
credit is it against business profits
tax and business enterprise tax yeah
both both
both both both bpt and bet
so
the other part of our meeting we talked
to again
it appears that so far they've attracted
they say okay
we go to department of revenue and say
well how many
we know it's under 10 because they won't
tell us
their rule is they want to give us any
taxpayer information if it's under 10
which is their rule which is probably
appropriate to try to protect
the businesses
and they feel
you know under 10 we can kind of work
backwards and figure out who's who so
so that's fine so we know it's under 10.
but she said there's probably six
businesses
that have come that have
can take advantage of it
using it using that uh bp but she wasn't
sure if they are she says they probably
aren't again when we passed this we knew
one thing
that all these small businesses weren't
going to be making a profit for a while
so we weren't too concerned about the
bpt
you know bankruptcy in the state
actually it's going to create more in 10
years we're going to reap the benefits
of this increase business
but
but they they do they have to pay bet
again but she wasn't sure whether they
were
filing with the dra and again we can't
get it out of the department we have a
very close working relationship with
department of revenue just like you have
a good working relationship with
department of labor
uh and they would tell us but and i even
went to the the commissioner to try to
get him for out of versus domino so
um
yeah but let's answer your question i
rejected sullivan
looking at the amendment um it
indicates that it's non-lapsing does
that mean that the million dollars goes
yet a year it
it moves from one year to another or
it's no opposed one yet another and
there's is there another million dollars
appropriated no we're just appropriating
one million one million period right
and actually you know in the original
bill we gave the business finance
authority
the um
also
the ability to bond money up to 5
million
that's not i don't think that's going to
happen
but
um
but we we we thought
we thought the one million was was
enough if if we see that there's
activity
and that you know we may come back to
the to the to the legislature again and
ask for for additional funding
but again but all of this ends in ten
years
okay and we're into year four already so
there's six years left
representative honey sorry
thank you mr chairman and uh
thank you representative taking the
question um should we have a six-year
sunset on this fund for the million
dollars
sydney is only goes for 10 years and
we're already into year four
you could do that but
i think we'll take care of it
i think we're under the clock to try to
get this passed at this point
uh you know what i mean it's
um
i think at that i think that at that
point in time we'll know we'll know the
six that's the final six years is up and
we'll i know in ways of means we'll make
sure that you know if we're all here
uh but we'll make sure that that that
that fund ends
then
i lost it thank you sorry thank you okay
thank you the uh i i would assume um
representative that since this whole
bill
it was initiated with 10 years
everything would stop at the end of the
10 years including this fund that's
right okay
any other questions
representative avalani any second
remembrance
okay you're recognized thank you um
seeing as if we adopt this amendment
we don't usually have the ability to
appropriate funds so would this make it
an fn bill
to make sure that it goes to a second
committee
so
want me to say that yeah it does make it
an fm bill and i've i've been
the last two days i've been um
maneuvering around trying to
trying to convince them not to have come
here have it go to finance
the amendment
uh but and i talked to representative
i said earlier representative romberger
this morning
she said she will be talking to the
speaker that it that it will come to it
will go to finance
it is the speaker's um
prerogative representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
browning
uh are there any other industries that
we have favored in this way
uh
no
this was this was a long and hard
discussion four years ago
um
and
it was
this was
an opportunity
i mean it's it's dean came in is quite a
salesman
uh
and he he he he
he said this is the this is gonna be the
renaissance of the manchester's
you know we're gonna go from our history
of being a mil you know
a hundred years ago being milltown
textile capital of the world
he's views this as being the textile cap
of the uh
generous medicine capital of the world
here
we i guess we all bought into that and
we'll see
it was but it was one that we kept on
saying to ourselves how much of a risk
is it really going to be in terms of the
to the taxpayer of giving these tax
breaks and it's turning out to be not
that much
and that that
like i said earlier knowing that these
startups are not going to be making big
profits anyway
so
we we said i think i think there's
something that we we do this could be
big this is cutting edge stuff
uh and we and it passed the house in the
senate pretty pretty handily as well so
um and the governor obviously supported
it
back then so
last follow-up and then we're gonna get
senator d'alessandro who might be able
to answer some questions but go ahead
with your follow-up representative
cahill uh i i was thinking that people
who are working in this field probably
have very advanced degrees and would
probably command a high salary
so
is there as much of a need to help pay
off their student loans as there might
be for other people in other industries
well when they yeah i think good
question yeah a lot of them have phds
but when they get more towards the
development of the manufacturing
processes
it's more technical level people that
they want to bring in so that they'd be
some of these education credits would go
to
[Music]
lower level if you will technical people
that will need to be trained in in the
processes that they come up with at that
other level because this is all about
and
and the reason the department of defense
came to cayman
is for one reason they said
you know how to get
things done you know how to get
manufacturing going and that's this is
why it's manufacturing it's it's
manufacturing institute
it's trying to take the science and and
create the product but then how do you
manufacture it by the way they're
talking about
basically using 3d printing we're
talking about 3d printing you know
kidneys and livers and whatever else
and we're we're there and we're getting
close we're getting close so
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you thanks
thank you thank you i think the next
call senator d'alessandro
oh son
representative alvin has a
pressure for a committee so
sure if that's all right representative
uh alma you're recognized thank you
i'm going to be
pretty quick i hope
on the
well
first
we asked a lot of really hard questions
about this project it took a long time
they thought i was trying to kill it
on i was trying to make sure that this
was going to work one of the things that
they were working on from the beginning
is lungs
building new lungs
and they have actually done
a fair amount of experimental
transplants into human beings who had no
other alternative to this one
already
i don't they're not there quite yet but
that is kind of the
the peak of of this work
is lungs are incredibly complicated
but
these are startups
and startups
are mostly run by young recent phds
straight out of the most advanced
on with new bright ideas nobody had
before
and
what they're doing is merging biological
science with mechanical engineering
and
it still has the it's been slow setting
up it still has the possibility of
of exploding into something huge
such as we had back in the
late in the late 70s 80s
in this state
and
on
so we decided that we were going to fund
that but we did not have the money to
fund
the tuition
grants
on for this
and
we asked key wallace the new head at
that point of the business finance
authority
uh to go out and try to raise the money
from donors
and
if he raised enough from donors they
were going to bond
the 5 million he cannot bond the 5
million dollars that they were asking
for
uh without having some kind of backup of
how do we pay for this
later he's a bank
so um
that didn't work out i don't know how
much effort he put into it
we did not have the money at that point
to be able to do that and we certainly
couldn't bond it through the regular
bonding process because it had already
been taken up it was the second year of
the biennium it was five years ago
um
so
that's why
it ended up not being funded most people
had forgotten that since then but
on
the finance we do have the money this
year the finance committee is willing to
to uh take care of it as long as they
don't have to pay anything in the future
and that's what the bill in front of you
does it says non-lapsing means that
on we aren't going to take the money
back away from you if you haven't
finished spending it yet
but it doesn't say we're going to give
you another million next year
so i hope that
clears up that part of it
thank you any question uh representative
warden thank you
two-part question
this
amendment that they're asking for is for
the current
fiscal year ending june
uh june 30th of this year so it goes
back in time two years right it's the
budget we passed two years ago is that
correct
uh no the the
army passed five years ago actually
but came into effect four years ago
although but the budget that this is
appropriate appropriation for is the
current budget that we're just finishing
up correct yeah
right okay follow up and
this
amendment refers to
chapter
section 162-t3
which was when the
army regenerative thing was originally
set up the credit
tax credit scheme
but in that
chapter it says for repayment of student
loan dues
the um i'll quote no forgiveness of such
student indebtedness shall be affected
unless the person shall have been
employed
to perform primarily active regenerative
manufacturing business activities at a
location within new hampshire for a
minimum period of five years
so we haven't even been into it five
years
what's the rush why couldn't we put it
in next year's budget because nobody
could even ask for student loan
indebtedness repayment until next year
that is quite easy our committee is very
worried that the money coming in next
year is going to be nothing like the
money coming in this that has come in
this year
and we also know that we owe back a
large amount of money to taxpayers
that they have left with us on deposit
on
some of it is because they paid taxes on
their pp
pay loans from the federal government
and every other state was giving
on
was telling them you don't have to pay
taxes on that we had to pass a law to do
that it took a long time they paid the
taxes before we did that we have to give
that money back
we thought they were going to start they
may still be giving it asking for it
right now
some of them
we have no idea how much of it is going
to have to be paid back in each year but
the total of it is
perhaps 90 million dollars
that's a big problem and we also have
300 million dollars on account uh in
something called credit carry forward
which on we just finally it has been
exploding
it was a hundred million ten years ago
four years ago it was 200 million and
now it is over 300 million
and they can come back at any time and
say we don't want to keep this on
deposit with you anymore we're going to
we want it back
so on we've been talking for quite a
long time led by our chair norman major
has been most insistent on this
on
about taking the
uh
figuring out a way to reduce that to
something more manageable part of it is
half of it we think is just on i put
this here and i'm going to be using it
all this year and it will be gone by the
end of this year
the other half is it's been there a
while
and those companies are still here
so um
we are
we started doing something about that in
the current budget
and it was a signal to the companies
that if you don't start taking this
money back you're going to have to take
it back all at once
and we think the reason that they've
kept it here is that it's cheaper than
taking it back and paying taxes on it to
the federal government
so on that that they may start asking
for more of that back
and we
most people think we're probably headed
into a recession
we don't know what kind of recession
so uh we don't want to depend on having
a lot of money next year
so you're all set representative warden
okay representative sullivan
uh representative almi you and i have
been having some discussions about this
bill and about the uh
the fact that it's rather bizarre that
the bill is in this committee
um it
ought to be either in ways and means or
in finance
or both
but
i i guess i would suggest to my labor
committee colleagues
that we stay in our lane
get out of the way
and just move this bill on to the
finance committee so they can take care
of it this is really not our area um
necessarily so um
i
i will accept your advice over the phone
that uh you know
this uh this bill needs needs to move
forward uh the amendment needs to move
forward and um we ought to just get her
done so um
what would you believe
yes i i just while i'm here i want to
thank uh senator d'alessandro for
putting this in it is simply a ways and
means bill
it was in the senate and it should have
been here but i don't know how you got
it
but now we've all learned something
thank you thank you representative all
mean
senator alessandro
thank you
thank you mr chairman
well it's been a very interesting
presentation i might say
i come before you as the prime sponsor
of senate bill 276. it was a very simple
bill
uh
as as has uh has has been iterated i
represent district 20 manchester awards
3 4 10 11 of the town of goffstown
i i was on ways and means when we uh
passed this bill four years ago
the purpose of the bill was such
we had a new concept that was being
developed it was called regenerative
manufacturing the department of defense
gave
dean cayman and deca
90 billion dollars to create a
not-for-profit
that would eventually get into the
business of regenerative manufacturing
what did that mean that means hearts
pancreases lungs livers could be
regenerated
they're currently working on the heart
as we speak
i was a sponsor of the bill
the rationale for the bill was it was
going to save millions and millions of
dollars
because the troops coming back
have very significant medical problems
they lose their limbs
there are other medical problems this
particular regenerative situation could
address some of those
make their lives better
and also save millions of dollars which
go in at infinatum
or until the death of the individual
so it made good sense
so what was the plan the plan was
what about the bpt and the bet could we
suspend payment of the bpt and the bet
for 10 years
so that this
program could get a very solid start the
90 million was part of the deal then
they would go out and they would sell
let's call it stock
to different companies so that they
would join in
about 250 entities have joined in
this process
one way or another they're they're
aiding the process in its development
so i visited them
and i said gee uh
it seems to me
we asked for a report on how things were
going
and i've never seen that report
so i've sent an email every month asking
for the report
i've no i've not seen it
the genesis of the bill
let's make sure that a report comes
we're doing a good service for them a
remarkable service to be honest with you
the suspension of the bpt and the bet
for 10 years
was it was an adventure
all right it's something that really had
to take a strong look at
but in return
we should get a report on how things are
going
so i visited
they are expanding the lab they are
using the lab at unh they're expanding
the lab
all of these things are in place but
what's the progress
and that in essence
is the genesis of my piece of
legislation and the reporting periods
that should come to the legislature come
to ways and means and come to finance in
both the house and the senate
we did we did uh
we took a very adventurous step forward
we should get an accounting of what's
going on
there may be others who'll come for this
and try to take advantage of this event
of this situation we'll have some record
we'll have of how things went the first
time we did it and what the positive
results are so therein is the
again the genesis of the legislation and
why this piece of legislation is before
you now with regard to the loan
repayment
we do we already do loan repayment uh in
a couple of areas by state primary care
does it for doctors who come to rural
areas
and uh there there's another one at hhs
for for a loan uh for loan repayment so
the question was is it being that yes
it's being done are we exercising it at
this point in time we just can't get any
people no never mind pay loans we give
five people
we can't find people to pay the loans
back for
but i think it's essential
that this committee or whoever you send
it to
pass the bill because we need
a very uh we d we need a a very
significant report
on a on a you know by
by legislative basis or you know every
six months
as to what's going on and we want
manchester to be the center of
regenerative manufacturing uh we have an
opportunity uh to lead the nation if not
the world i mean the cayman has been
brilliant
in in many of his adventures
uh and i think the insolent pope it has
to be the
the the crowdy glory of his uh
his achievements never by the segway and
the uh wheelchair and and so forth but
uh
he's done some remarkable things
this gives an opportunity for more
remarkable things and
uh that mr achievement is my rationale
for producing the bill and i'll be happy
to answer any queries that anybody has
with regard to the legislation thank you
senator are there any questions from the
senator
seeing none thank you very much thank
you thank you for your attention
appreciate your support
i don't know where it's going but at
least not to pass thank you
thank you does anyone else like to speak
on behalf of uh hospital 276 or against
seeing none i'm going to close the
hearing on senate bill 276 and move on
to the rest of our agenda
i do not have any pink cards or senate
bill 377 fn relative to the eligibility
of certain injuries for state troopers
or
for workers compensation
i need a
representative cahill would you please
take the chair and just
uh for as a member of the legislature
introduce
house bill 377.
um oh
senator
yes i
i i apologize chantal i i uh
my apologies i shouldn't tell um wheeler
on behalf of senator carson thank you
oh
my name is chantelle wheeler and i am
pleased to be here on behalf of senator
sharon carson who represents senate
district 14 comprising the towns of
londonderry auburn and hudson i'm here
to present for your consideration
senate bill 377.
um as amended this bill creates a
presumption that an injured injury is
occupationally caused if it occurs while
a state trooper is operating a state
police vehicle in the performance of
their official duties
the language of this bill deals with a
current gap in the law regarding workers
compensation for our troopers on the
road due to a change in contracts
command staff are not recognized as
being paid until they arrive at
headquarters even though they may be in
uniform
and fully marked cars and they may have
to answer calls on their drive in in a
similar vein when troopers do extra duty
details like working a construction job
on the highway or hampton beach these
troopers do not get paid for the commute
to the site a concern has been raised
that during the commute time if an
officer is injured in an accident or by
some other manner because they are not
viewed under the law as on duty at the
time then that injury may not be covered
by workers compensation
this bill addresses that by creating a
presumption that if a trooper is
operating a cruiser and in their uniform
on the way to state function they will
be covered under workers compensation
and that concludes my introduction and i
thank you
thank you are there any questions
representative warden
you may know the answers but thanks for
taking the question
are there some troopers that take their
state police vehicles home with them yes
if a state trooper
were
if since he some of them can take them
home with them he finishes up the day
working
and then continues in his vehicle his or
her vehicle to have dinner
and a few drinks
and then
on the way home from the restaurant or
bar
crashes
would this
bill give that person coverage
regardless of the cause of the accident
or the level of sobriety
in this hypothetical situation of the
trooper regrettably i'm not able to
answer that but i know there are
experts in the industry behind me who
are
here to do that and i would prefer to
divert to them no no problem i didn't
want to put jones by thank you
representative we have someone coming
from this uh new hampshire troopers
association afterwards that can answer
some of those specifics but i would i
would gather that uh they have to report
from their job right to their home not
stopping at restaurants or bars i'm just
going to go on the limb and say that but
we'll wait in here let's see what they
say we're going to wait and hear what
um
brian ross has to say in a moment um
chantal is uh or i'm sorry i apologize i
i don't need to use you by your first
name uh miss wheeler um it is my
understanding that
the current new now
you said it was about a contract
correct because current new hampshire
law if someone's driving with a company
vehicle from their home to their job
site
okay
that there is coverage under certain
under most circumstances
not necessarily to their office
to just check in and then go to a job
site but right to their job
was there a situation such as the the
unfortunate um
trooper that got killed on in on on 93
or 95 when he was at a duty on was there
a situation that has occurred that
you're aware of where coverage was
denied i am not aware okay i'll ask the
next speaker are there any other
questions for
mr wheeler
thank you very much for introducing the
bill and your testimony i'd like to
introduce brian ross the hampton
troopers association we're going to
grill him something fierce
good morning
good morning welcome i am brian ross i'm
here to represent the new hampshire
troopers association um i've been with
the state police for over 14 years now
um
and just uh start off with uh rep
warden's question um
we are not allowed to consume any kind
of alcoholic beverages while we are on
duty nor are we allowed to use our state
police cruisers
when we are in an off-duty capacity
so
um the situation of stopping at a
restaurant on the way home
and i think you said having a few drinks
with dinner or something along those
lines um our policies and procedures uh
forbid us from doing that
um and just uh
reiterate what was already said with um
the introduction of the bill
i have the opportunity to work um
off-duty construction details or extra
duty details and there's been numerous
times where i have been traveling to or
from that extra
detail
where i was the closest unit to an
active call on the radio and i had to
respond there
before the duty unit could get there
and start handling the situation i'm
just speaking with another trooper this
morning he talked about just a couple
days ago being on an extra duty detail
on 93 in concord
and um he was traveling home from that
detail and responded to the canterbury
arrest area uh for a medical call and he
was the first one there
before any on duty units could get there
just because of his proximity to that
location um and i only bring that up um
just because traveling to and from our
extra duty details or the command staff
traveling to and from headquarters
there are many times when technically
we're considered to be in an off-duty
status
but we're called to
be act in an on-duty capacity
to align with our job duties as a state
trooper as we are in full uniform at the
time and in a state police car
um
to answer your question representative
infantine sorry if i mispronounced the
um
it's been a lot worse pronunciation of
your name
the um
i don't personally know of a situation
where um a trooper wasn't covered
um this is
to ensure that um we are covered if that
situation did occur and um going back to
staff sergeant cheryl's situation um
where he was killed on i-95 in an
automobile accident
he was
working in a capacity of a
construction detail um so it's my
understanding that um he he was covered
as a line of duty injury in that
situation
excellent
are there any questions for mr ross
representative mandeville
thank you mr chairman thank you for
coming and forgive the naivete of this
question but
um are there any
uh state troopers who are not required
in the context of their employment to be
in uniform such that they might
lose the presumption
that's covered by this bill because
while they're in the vehicle they're not
in a uniform
yes but in that situation um for example
i'm a detective so i drive to and from
um the office i'm not in a uniform but
i'm considered in an on duty status at
that time um
the
situations
that um we're looking to have covered um
typically would be
in a uniform capacity but either way
we're just looking to have the off-duty
status be covered by workman's comp
well as i read the uh proposed bill um
it would it requires for the presumption
to kick in
the operating of the police vehicle and
wearing the uniform of the day
i just i'm not entirely sure whether
that works an unintended disadvantage
okay
and um
just to clarify what uniform of the day
means to me
um if you're a uniform trooper whether
it be command staff or a trooper um the
class b or c
b being the um
long-sleeve winter uniform or c being
the summer uniform
that would be the uniform of the day but
also for detectives who wear plain
clothes their uniform of the day is
the plainclothes dress of yeah shirt and
tie and jacket so
represent
okay
representative uh avaloni
thank you mr chairman thank you for
checking the questions
probably a couple um
so the troopers take their cars home
and report to work when do they sign in
for their job
and sign out
when they get home or when they're
actually their shift is over
um
for the majority of troopers it's um
when you leave your house in your
cruiser we sign on via radio and then we
sign off via radio when we get back home
at our house so for the majority of
troopers you're on duty when you leave
your driveway in the state police car
and you're off duty when you get
back home the difference is is for those
extra duty details when we're traveling
to and from the construction site um we
are technically in an off-duty capacity
and that is the concern so you're really
signing into those jobs when you're
meeting up with the contractor wherever
that extra duty detail
is
what if it is not an off-duty detail say
you're attending a funeral out of states
and you're attending a funeral in
a different part of the state you're in
your
uniform with the with the
your assigned car
with this
as this is written at least to me
you would be covered under workman's
comp if you sustained an injury
outside of your normal
operations of your vehicle yes i i
suppose that would be another uh
situation where
you could be in an off-duty capacity
um and traveling to or from a funeral
that would have to be approved in order
for us to
do those things um the director would
have to approve us to
be in uniform and travel to or from a
funeral or awake or whatever the
ceremony is in the state car so i guess
that would be another situation where we
could be in an off-duty capacity
um
being in uniform and traveling to or
from a funeral
i can also say that
um
in funerals that i've attended in the
past um the director of the colonel has
indicated that um whoever wants to
attend this funeral it could be um a
duty day so sometimes
um
we're allowed to modify our schedule
if we were on a day off um in order to
attend a funeral or that kind of
ceremonial proceeding
in an on duty capacity
follow up if i could yes
so do other
uniformed officers
do the same type of duty off duty when
they're doing extra details like we see
county sheriffs or we see other officers
in other towns
doing the same
you know construction jobs or monitoring
wires or something like that
should this be only for state troopers
or should we be looking to expand this
to
other departments that do the same type
of
i don't want to pretend to have
knowledge about um the sheriff's
department or local department's
uh detail policies and whether or not
they get paid um
traveling to or from
those extra duty details
um so i don't want to comment on that um
but i could see that
there may be other
organizations who have that same
issue of
wanting their employees to be covered
traveling
to or from these extra duty details in
in a state vehicle or in a county or
town vehicle
thank you thank you for taking questions
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony i want to follow up on
the you mentioned the ceremonial detail
is
that also
a case where
if you're on an off-duty ceremonial
detail and something occurs
could that officer be called upon to
respond to a situation or is that a
different animal than what we're talking
about with the construction details i
would say yes because if we're in if
we're in the worker and we're in
especially when we're in uniform um our
policies and procedures indicate that we
are expected to take appropriate action
thank you mr ross in addition you would
be um
traveling
to
training
uh
going to the gun range and all those
other things as well
correct that could necessarily be
driving to there
or back
that that for training that necessarily
isn't
um
you know before your duty shift would
start
so in those situations though where we
are traveling let's say to the gun range
for training um
we're in an on duty capacity already
okay
any questions for mr ross uh
representative warden thank you thanks
for taking a call
are troopers allowed to
take civilian passengers in their car
let's say they
finish their shift and then go to pick
up a spouse or from work or child from
school are they allowed to do that in
their trooper vehicles
we
aren't supposed to use our vehicles in
an off-duty capacity
whether or not
you can pick up
a spouse or a family member in the state
vehicle i believe
and i don't have the policy in front of
me but i believe you need to get prior
authorization to be able to do that
hey thank you
i see no further questions
mr ross thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
i saw um
just a commissioner ogden
pulling a uh
a pink card was that for this hearing or
another one
okay would you like to speak at all
uh mr commissioner
nope all right
always like
you have a question for the commissioner
would you mind please coming to the
podium please for a question from mr
avilani
be gentle we gotta we gotta go with our
agenda here we gotta get cracking
thank you mr chairman thank you deputy
commissioner um have you had
listening to the testimony would do you
think there would be
issues if we passed this to expand it to
just state troopers
i'm not sure and i i would defer to
perhaps others more familiar with law
enforcement in general my understanding
is is that certain municipalities they
don't take the vehicles home so i don't
know that it's as much of an issue
uh so again similar to mr ross's
testimony i don't know that i'm informed
enough to offer you know whether that's
a problem that exists or not
thank you welcome
thank you
is there anyone else like to speak on
senate bill 377 fn
seeing none i will close the hearing and
try to get back on track for my mom
senate bill 209 relative to electronic
wage payments
i do not have i vote
this wheeler
all right i'd like to um call chantal
wheeler on behalf of senator carson one
of the
sponsors of the bill
miss wheeler
good morning and thank you for having me
i am here on behalf of senator sharon
carson from senate district 14
representing hudson auburn in
londonderry i have for your
consideration senate bill 209 which
would amend the statutory provisions
related to the payment of an employee's
wage by direct deposit 29 states
including maine and massachusetts have
enacted similar legislation and the
committee also heard that 93 percent of
u.s workers already receive their wages
through direct deposit if a worker does
not have a bank account then they have
an option to receive a payroll card
there are no fees associated with the
payroll card unless an out of network
atm is used and they are not subject to
overdraft or non-sufficient fund fees
the committee amendment established a
process for an employee to be provided
their wages when they cannot access them
due to a technical or processing defect
this addressed a concern raised by the
department of labor especially in
circumstances where employees cannot
access funds from their payroll card in
addition a change was made to rsa 275 43
2c to ensure consistency in the statute
and that concludes my introduction
you have any questions for the presenter
the chairman does
line 17 on page one
refers to line 15 having to do with an
employee unable to access their wages
due to technical or processing defect
and then in line 19 in such a situation
the employer shall be liable for late
payment of wages
whenever the replacement pages are
provided under the designated pay after
the designated payday so my question in
my voicemail to the senator was
well if this is a bank problem
bank had a hiccup
why is the employer responsible for
late payments
and what is a late payment does this
mean that one of your employees has
direct payment off of their
checking account every month and if the
payment's late and those payments all go
out and the money is not there
then there are going to be um bounce
check fees late fees penalties and such
so
it's just a little too vague for me and
that's where i kind of like to
understand what this means
i thank you for your question
unfortunately i'm not able to answer
that i would need to defer
okay
um
respectfully to the senator we're going
to kind of need to know a little more
specifics on that
as it is now i'm uncomfortable with just
giving it a thumbs up
other than that
i'm okay with the bill as is that's i
think it's
you know it's
unfortunately upon us to think of the
good the bad and the ugly of everything
we write and how it's going to be you
know interpreted
are there any other questions for the
presenter
all right thank you very much thank you
for your time
like to call on w commissioner ogden
from the new hampshire department of
labor
the man with the answers
uh good morning thank you uh chairman
infants hein and committee uh for the
record my name is rudy ogden i'm deputy
commissioner for the department of labor
um i did want to start just in terms of
context
some of the folks who have been part of
the committee for some time knows that
when these bills or bills related to pay
cards have come up in the past the
department has historically had
concerns relative to payment processes
or payment platforms such as pay cards
uh being mandated those concerns have
principally been based in three areas
for and some of these areas are really
policy decisions that the committee
needs to make
relative to their feelings on these
types of platforms but in terms of what
the concerns are or have been first is
the idea of choice the issue of whether
someone should be compelled to take
payment on a pay card or not i would
note that this bill does say that the
individual would have the ability to say
i want payment via direct deposit it
would be in instances in which they
cannot or do not set up direct deposit
that they can be pushed to the platform
of pay cards one thing we do have to
remember though is that there is a
number of folks and i think the number
is larger than we sometimes think who
are what they would call unbanked and
when you talk about folks who are
unbanked they are folks who are for
whatever reason sometimes it's choice
sometimes it's inability or lack of
financial literacy they do not have
the wherewithal to set up bank accounts
and do things of that nature those folks
generally the department has always had
concerns with is that typically and this
is a gross generalization but typically
in the department's experience a lot of
times the folks who are unbanked are the
lower wage earners so as there has been
this heightened concern of lower wage
earners on a pay card being subject to
fees
uh that brings us to the second concern
so if the first is choice whether they
should have the choice or not the second
being fees
i would be clear that this
language in this says that they should
be able to withdraw one at least one
time per pay period for the full balance
of their pay without fee so if that's
happening that is no different than now
the idea that you should be able to go
and cash a check
without a fee at a financial institution
so the the language of the bill does say
that and the language of pay cards has
said that for some time
i would just point out that sometimes
the use of these pay cards and i did get
a question from one of the
representatives representative schmidt
had talked about the various programs
there are a whole host of pay card
programs or platforms out there the
department does not understand to have
an encyclopedic recall on how all of
them work some of them do have a lot of
fees and when i talk about fees they
talk about fees relative to transfers
fees relative to using them as debit
cards or other things of that nature but
this does say that they should at least
have a fee less opportunity for the
person to withdraw their full payment uh
that's very important in any instance in
which
a pay card did not provide that it would
be in violation of this whether this
amendment goes forward or not or this
bill goes forward or not
the last concern that the department has
had and i think this somewhat speaks to
representative infantine your part
questions related to that language that
was inserted is when we testified in the
senate we did bring up that there have
been instances when we've dealt with pay
cards where the problem has been
accessed so the employer has a pay card
uh invite they have a pay card that they
give to their employees even if
employees might at present they're
choosing to be on the pay card and when
they go to use it
they can't it's not working and then
when they go to the pay card the the
they go to their employer they say hey i
can't get my payment the employer says
deal with the pay card company i i don't
deal with that you know i've paid it you
deal with the pay card company sometimes
then they go deal with the pay card
company they're like well there's a
problem with what your employer has done
or not done and i think the intent of
the language here i understand what
you're saying is that it's somewhat
broad but the intent of the language
here is to just make very plain that if
there was a late payment because the
payment process did not work
uh the employer would be expected to
make that individual
whole and timely they should be doing it
timely we've had these examples or
instances in which someone has been
waiting for a week or two weeks or three
weeks for the pay card stuff to sort
itself out and the person is at that
point going unpaid uh for some
significant period of time so certainly
i think the language could be you know
tightened or made more explicit in what
we're talking about but i think that was
what the intent was and i don't mean to
speak for the senator but i believe that
when senator soucy was looking to add an
amendment to the initially offered
language that was the concern was this
access the idea that there have been
instances in which employees have said i
can't get the pay card to work the
employer's not helping them because
they're saying hey i've offloaded that i
have a vendor that handles that deal
with them and then the vendor is not we
cannot do anything to the vendor if the
payment is late the department of labor
has no ability to say to the vendor pay
them on time or get it fixed so that's
kind of where it's come up as a concern
so i'm happy to take any questions and
again i would just note that
we do appreciate some of the changes
that have been made to this to really
clarify that the employer is expected to
make the payment timely and make the
individual whole if there are pro
processing problems
thank you questions representative c
work
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you for
testifying on this
my question goes back a number of years
we've heard
similar bills in the past and
frequently
the issues you alluded to where pay
cards have caused problems particularly
for this unbanked segment
of the workforce
and my question is
based on the department's experience
with those problems how does it compare
with that same segment trying to deal
with caching checks in other words my
question is is it really the cases has
been suggested before that pay cards are
tend to have more problems than
say an unbanked person trying to get
their money from a check
or
is the issue really with the unbanked
situation rather than the means of
trying to pay them the biggest issues
that we've come across with pay cards
and i'm talking my turn with the
departments relatively the last eight
years typically what has come up as
problem has been fees but i do want to
be very clear that the fees have not
been in the environment of the person
was not able to get their
payment without a fee at least once it's
that they've used the card the cards
offer a number of different you can make
transfers you can use it as a debit card
you can do a lot of different things
with these cards that are sometimes
convenient but there are costs to those
conveniences and what we have had is we
have had instances in which employees
have used the cards they've incurred a
number of fees and then when they've
dealt to with us we've looked at it and
said okay well you were using it though
that way so it wasn't necessarily there
were a lot of fees uh whether you know
they knew that there were going to be
all those fees up front some of the
literature is better than others when
you look at certain of what they get
when they're onboarded
but again so we have not seen there be
fee problems in the sense of not being
able to get the payment at least once if
that's what they wanted to do without a
fee the other problem has been a choice
where presently the law says that you
cannot compel someone to use a pay card
what we have run across in several
instances and it's mainly been employers
who are through multiple jurisdictions
so they have a program that they're
saying okay we've opened in new
hampshire and now we want to start doing
this it's at time of onboard they're
telling the folks you're on the pay card
and they're not making plain to them
that they uh do or should have the
choice to elect a paper check
thank you that was very helpful
um
mr ogden um
do you have any idea how many
approximate
pay cards are out there how many
employers or how many employees are on a
pay card situation i don't i don't have
that okay
second on line 18
in such a situation the employer shall
be liable for late payment of wages
what does that mean
it means that it would be considered a
late payment so if
if
the person was supposed to get paid on
friday when they go to use the pay card
on friday it does not work if they're
not able to access the the wages friday
starting the next day they are now
that's a late payment we would consider
them liable for those late wages and
once they're liable for late wages it
would be expected that they make them
whole in the immediate that they don't
wait till the next pay period that they
don't wait till the next pay cycle that
they say
person should have been paid friday i
need to make them whole as soon as i'm
aware of it
but
there aren't any um i have a follow-up
please brian
thank you that does not mean that
there's a is there a labor department
fine is that liable is there uh are they
liable for again for
fees that they incurred for maybe a
an automatic payment
uh
liable in the sense of being used in
this section of statute would be liable
one for the the payment the actual wages
two there would be a civil penalty for a
late payment so in an instance in which
an employer does not correct that
um and make them uh whole on that day
uh they it would be a late payment with
a civil penalty of up to twenty five
hundred dollars
thank you representative abalone
thank you mr chairman just for
clarification when you say late payment
for wages that doesn't mean if they're
on friday you know their mortgage comes
out of that debit card and it bounces
would the employer be liable for any
fees occurred with that
payment not going through being returned
or anything like that
i'm sorry could you just
they wouldn't be liable for
they'd be liable for the wages the sum
total of the wages if they're uh
i'm not just explain the
apologies representative just explain in
terms of the so friday they can't access
their money to transfer to their
personal account and their mortgage
bounces that afternoon the bank assesses
the fee the mortgage company assesses a
fee would the employer be liable for
those fees
if they came to you and said because he
can't pay his mortgage because he didn't
get his pay right so there's a 50 fine
or 20 you know a fee or something for
late payments or if it was a direct
deposit right from his debit card or his
card
to the bank and it bounces
so there's a fee plus a late fee is that
they could be liable for the fees
relative to what the bank is charging
them but not if they owed the money to
someone else and that other entity was
then also charging them the fine if that
fee if that makes sense
when
yeah when we do a wage adjustment now if
if you're if the bank is finding you
we're finding you this amount of money
because your account was overdrawn we do
attribute that to the employer but if
the person's not able to make their
payment to their landlord
and then the landlord charges them a
late fee that would not necessarily
carry through but any of the fees
directly charged through the account
would be
just checking eyes everyone
representative schmidt
thank you uh thank you deputy
commissioner it was nice to hear from
you thank you for responding to my email
i had sent everybody in the committee uh
the latest
issue that i saw with pay cards
ask hank had to go out and find out what
happened to a woman's full account
she had
found that every transaction that she
made took a three dollar fee
and so she decided to let it build up
suddenly disappeared and i know that
they had to deal with the pay card
company they're not exactly sure what
happened
and the
restaurant that she was working for
refused to discuss it with her
the money that she earns at a restaurant
is her money
and if it isn't paid if the pay card
does something with it that the
restaurant's still responsible to pay
her yes
correct absolutely
i had thought that this issue was closed
but it looks like it's just getting
moved aside new pay cards being used
new fees on some of these things
overdraft fees that are happening to
people because they're taking off a fee
each time
um
what how many how many issues do you see
coming to you directly from employees
on pay cards
thank you for the question
representative we do not see a lot of
pay card issues uh come to us again as i
was speaking uh to representative
seaworth's question uh
it does not come up that often and when
it comes up it's principally in the
realm of they were not they were forced
to use it
that's usually been the issue that has
come up at least in the years that i've
been with the department we have had
instances i know the case you're talking
about the case you're talking about
ultimately she did recover all the wages
but certain of the fees she was accruing
were related to transfers she was trying
to make or as you're saying one-time
purchases which again there are fees
depending upon how you want to use
these cards but it was not an instance
in which she was not able to get her
payment
and not have a fee you know she could go
on payday and pull her payment that was
not the problem the problem was
transfers and then also purchases and as
she was doing that the the fees were
piling up to your point
follow up
um
clearly
a people who are having a problem with
this don't understand the process really
well
what happens when a pay card is
instituted by a company do they have to
explain everything that happens with
that pay card to that employee so they
can understand clearly when the fees are
taken
because all the fees are different
depending on the pay card
i can imagine it can be very complex
present law does provide that they are
supposed to receive a disclosure they
are supposed to receive a statement
disclosing those fees the nature of
those fees and the magnitude of those
fees
we know that some of the problems that
are happening are with people who are
unbanked obviously um they may have a
problem with language they may have a
problem with reading uh handing somebody
a document that says you're going to be
charged for this
they might not fully understand is there
any way to assure
that it is a full understanding of the
employee when a pay card is used
i don't know that there is a way um
i think that that would be very
difficult in terms of putting into law i
think that it would be hard to say that
uh someone you'd have to be you know or
we at that point considering capability
capacity competency in terms of
measuring those things i don't i
understand exactly the concern you're
identifying i don't know it's certainly
not addressed in present law and i don't
know of a neat way to address it uh here
another question for you um
so if a situation occurred where there's
a technical or processing deficit on a
friday
the person could not access their money
the
there's an issue with the pay card which
no one can figure out
at the present time
that individual by this if this law
passes would have the ability to demand
um
direct deposit cash or a check
immediately
correct so
we're not gonna hear
that at two o'clock when everyone else
gets paid another way and this
individual cannot use their card
we're not going to hear the employer say
at four o'clock i'm not going to do that
because if i pay you now and then the
pay card kicks in for some reason over
the weekend on monday you've been paid
twice i'm not gonna pay you you'll just
have to wait three two or three days
we're not going to have that situation
are we i believe again not to speak for
the senator but i believe that as part
of the intent of this language is at
present that is one of the issues with
the pay cards is that
a problem comes up and then the employer
says i've already dealt with this
through the pay card company so i am not
dealing with it in the present they wait
for it to sort out and sometimes it can
take days weeks to sort out and the
person's gone unpaid or late paid
throughout that time so if an employer
decides that they're gonna use a pay
card and there's a hiccup for no matter
what reason
they'll be responsible first they can
deal with the pay card company later
correct and one thing that i would also
just want to point out is
with a check it works the same way if
presently an employer had a problem
paying with checks
we would look at the employer to correct
that not say well the bank's going to
fix it or the bank messed up my payroll
account we would look to the employer to
fix that in the immediate i think what
we've experienced sometimes is
again not a not on a lot of instances
but we have experienced issues with the
pay cards where there has been that lag
and it has really been detrimental to
the employees affected
thank you are there any other questions
for debbie commissioner representative
sullivan and followed by uh abuelani
have there been instances where you have
um levied fines against
companies that
are
in late payment status
i believe so yes i can check to confirm
that but yes if there was a late payment
there would have been fines and late
payment is one of the instances in which
there's not a first a warning so when
that's come up i'm certain there have
been penalties thank you
you mr chairman thank you again deputy
commissioner so um under it says 915 due
to a technical processing defect
so say the they put in their wrong pin
number and this is completely user error
and it doesn't reset for 24 hours and
they can't access their money till say
monday
is the employer at fault
it's possible in the given scenario that
could fall under the language that's
been put forth here
thank you mr chairman and thank you
deputy commissioner for taking my
question
i'm concerned that this is a this
becomes a
a requirement for for employment
that uh if you if you don't if you're
unbanked for whatever reason
and you don't want to payroll if you
don't want to pay a real card because
maybe you're concerned about all the
fees and what else could happen you
don't have a choice anymore
would you believe
yes you are correct in the sense of
presently uh individuals can say that
they want to check
uh and they can
be paid by a check
with the language put forth in the
proposed legislation
an employer could say i'm going to pay
via direct deposit and it would be in
instances in which the person does not
take direct deposit or cannot take
direct deposit they could then the
employer then could say well you're
being paid via pay card
well
so if if the reason i don't i can't take
direct deposit is because the the
regular banks have such high minimum
monthly balances
i can't afford to have a hundred dollars
in the account and maybe like i don't
have a credit union near me that i could
join where they where they don't have
these outrageous fees and requirements
uh like can i take the debit card and
get my sister or my my neighbor to cash
it for me
i probably can't do that like i could
with a check
the
payroll cards are as put forth here they
should be able to go to a financial
institution convenient to the place of
employment and do one
felis withdrawal
and at banks where you don't have an
account they often charge you seven
eight ten dollars to cash that check
that that is drawn on the bank would
that be the case with this payroll card
so under present law employers are
supposed to ensure that they have an
arrangement with a bank so that even if
individuals did not have an account they
would not be subject to a fee
that should in under
this legislation it's to extend that to
pay cards that again individuals would
be able to present them
even if they don't have a particular
relationship with a bank that is the way
that this is intended to work if that's
not happening or doesn't happen that
would be in violation of this of this
language
and if the bank
that's designated is not convenient to
the employee and the employee goes to
another bank
there's a fee
if the employee decides to go to an
inconvenient
location that would not be a violation
the requirement is that there be a
convenient location
there has to be a convenient location
for the individual to do this if they
cannot do that because it's it doesn't
exist then the employer is in violation
if the individual decides to go
someplace else and incurs a fee that
would not be in violation of this
statute
thank you
thank you mr chairman um line 22
of the second page
um
actually starts on line 20 if anybody
wants to read it shall result in wage
payments via payroll card um are we
mandating payroll cards if there's only
an electronic means or should it be up
to the employer to provide another an
alternative means
or they should be locked into a payroll
card there you would not be locking
employ employers would be able to say
i'm paying via check or they could say
in practice i think how this would work
is the employer could elect to say i
want to pay everyone via a direct
deposit if there are individuals who
cannot take it under direct deposit they
could
mandate uh a payroll card if the
employer does not want to use a payroll
card they could then say okay i can't
direct deposit this person i'll give
them a check
you wouldn't be necessarily forcing the
employer to use the payroll card you'd
be forcing the employee to use the
payroll card but not the employer
they're very good questions
thank you chairman infantine vice
chairman seaworth and committee members
um my name is pete iceberg i'm vice
president of government relations for
adp which is the largest payroll company
in the nation we pay one out of every
six u.s workers
we think this bill will help both
workers and employers it'll help
employers meet their wage and and our
law obligations to pay workers on time
it can be impossible for employers to
pay workers on time you know in
situations where there's physical
delivery problems like bad weather which
is not unusual here
or the recent government shutdowns
related to covet electronic payments
eliminate this concern
it
you was
really again impossible to deliver paper
paychecks when the businesses themselves
were shut down the employees were at
home how do you get paper paychecks to
the people who need that they can't get
to the bank
so if there's a snowstorm on payday god
forbid no one is getting paid and that's
a problem
so this this fixes that employers should
be able to offer the choice of direct
deposit or payroll cards electronic
payments through direct deposit or
payroll cards is an efficient reliable
and cost-saving move for employers in
new hampshire a major improvement over
paper checks for employees
again most states already allow this 29
states permit electronic wage payments
including maine and massachusetts
employers that prefer to offer paper
payroll checks would certainly be free
to continue doing so so for example if
an employer had a collective bargaining
agreement they would probably just
continue offering paper paper checks
until the union uh you know agreed
otherwise and and people are used to
this already most payments are already
electronic virtually all government
payments are electronic such as tax
refunds unemployment insurance social
security nutrition assistance
disability and so on those are all
electronic 93
of american workers are already paid via
direct deposit
so we're just talking about that last
seven percent
and government employees are generally
all paid electronically so this is
something that's you know really only a
problem in the private sector
payroll cards have evolved to be much
better for consumers than um you know
we've heard uh we also saw you know
negative accounts in the past i think
that's been addressed now this is a
debit card like any other so you can use
it for spending at any retail
establishment and get cash back you can
walk into any bank that has a visa or
mastercard logo walk up to the teller
ask them for the full amount there's no
fee for that
so very easy to transact
uh you basically you really have to go
out of your way to to pay a fee to use
this card uh you know the only the only
cost typically is to use an out of
network atm and we make it pretty easy
to find in network atms through you know
just on your phone app whereas and
where's my free atm very easy to find
there are free withdrawals at lots of
major retailers uh walmart ninety
percent of the population live within
uh i think it's five miles of a walmart
walgreens cvs target rite aid circle k
costco all those major retailers they
have those all point
atms and there's free transactions there
card holders can use payroll cards
anywhere they would use a check
maybe with the uh
exception that you couldn't just sign it
over to somebody else your your spouse
your friend something like that
you know so that that that's a problem
but you know it enables people to do you
know free online bill payment
you know this is a functional bank
account uh you do internet shopping you
couldn't do otherwise if you're using
you know paper checks uh very
importantly there are the visa and
mastercard protections from fraud
in in dispute resolution so that's a
huge advantage for folks that are today
are in the cash economy
they cannot be overdrafted there are no
nsf fees on these payroll cards
they often include free savings accounts
and additional cards for family members
so it's a good choice for people with
kids in college just want to give them a
spending account with a certain amount
each month
and frankly paper checks are pretty bad
choices for workers who have to present
their check you know assuming they have
a bank account and wait for that check
to clear
those without bank accounts typically
have to pay check cashing fees
and then carry their full paycheck in
cash which is subject to loss or theft
there's also
most recently earlier availability with
electronic wage payments many banks now
credit electronic payroll payments a day
or two before payday
and electronic wage statements the pay
stubs are are generally also available
before payday so this is better for
workers and for employers we see it as a
matter of when not if
european workers for example haven't
seen a paper paycheck in decades
um
i do want to respond to one question
that came up and that was related to the
unbanked this actually helps unbanked
folks they can't get a bank account
today because they can't walk into the
bank maybe they're undocumented but if
they can get a job you have to have a
social security number to get you know
to be employed but if you can get a job
the bank system relies on employers to
do the know your customer authentication
verification so
they can they can get a job they can get
a payroll card this is a functional bank
account that they could not get
before getting this job so they can
pay their bills electronically all that
good stuff
so it actually helps helps the
undocumented
and i'm happy to answer your questions
thank you very much for your testimony
uh representative cahill
thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question uh
i realized that adp is a predominant
handle of payroll but you're not the
only debit card in town
so could you speak to the possibility i
mean i've heard about people having fees
for balance inquiry
is that something that doesn't happen
with adp
uh correct yeah that doesn't happen we
basically that the list of fees have
gone down to pretty much zero the only
the only fee for adp i can say is uh if
you're using an out-of-network atm
um and again we make it pretty easy to
find an in-network atm
follow-up but again you you can only
speak for adp debit cards
uh that's true yeah so there are other
cards they have they have their own fee
disclosure statements and employers you
know if they they may choose a
a card arrangement with um adverse fees
you know some other states have um
prohibited
feed you know
account balance inquiry fees and things
like that so those little nuisance fees
if if they're concerned but usually that
sorts itself out in the marketplace
employers you know tend to to use the
best uh
systems that are out there
another follow-up another follow-up
and again the employers are the one
making the decision on which car which
payroll card to offer
not necessarily consulting their
employees or how this is going to work
for them
um
and and it's the the issue of the issue
of the direct deposit which i personally
have in my my 100 a year it shows up
right on times don't worry
but
isn't that isn't that something that's
less problematic if a person can have
that than the payroll cards we don't
hear about trouble with with the deposit
not getting there with your direct
deposit whereas payroll cards we refer
to litany of other complaints about them
i'm not sure understood the question it
sounds like there may be technical
problems with delays in payments on
payroll cards in payroll cards are seem
to be more problematic than okay than
direct deposit if you're able to manage
the direct deposit through perhaps one
of those credit unions that isn't as uh
greedy in their fees as a normal bank
yeah
um yeah i would say um
direct payroll cards are really the
functional equivalent of direct deposit
in the sense of
uh being um
you know problem free like the same they
they run on the same guard
the same systems as direct deposit so
the banking system um is is
indistinguishable it's the same the
problems come in with the confusion of
employees of you know where do i have my
pin where's my pin what's my password
how do i use this card can i take it
here can i take it there i i had a
question from a bank total that didn't
know what they were doing uh when i went
to ask them to you know cash that the
fee we've actually you know for example
published letters given letters to
employees saying you know just take this
to your teller if they give you any
difficulty it directs them to contact
you know corporate and let them you know
confirm that there's no fee associated
with this that kind of thing
so there are some there's some confusion
about sometimes how do i use this card
and um to you know the the deputy
commissioner's um
statement you know it really
we believe it it is a responsibility the
employer if an employee does have
difficulties you know regardless of what
the cause was to help them through that
one more
final follow-up yes final fantasy this
is my final question so
okay
so if you uh if you have the the card
or sorry if you have the check it
usually comes with a pay stub
and you can keep track of your hours and
your vacation time well how do you do
this with a debit card sure
um
people who get uh payroll cards get the
same pay stub as anybody that gets a
check they just get it electronically
and again it's pretty employers um put
this on a secure kiosk and they keep
records forever so it's actually better
than you know having something printed
that you need to then keep track of
stuff in your pocket forget where you
put it you don't know where it is it's
going to be on that secure internet
portal forever whenever you need it back
10 years whatever
something like that but and it's fairly
easy to do also if an employee does want
to print that
the employers typically have a secure
printing area like a kiosk in the
employer's office where the employee can
just go and print their pay stubs if
they just want a printed pay stub but
it's it's all very easy and secure and
they this is how they interact with
employers generally anyway um through
those these employee portals for their
benefits and things like that
thank you very much thank you
any further questions
ah representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman
um
it um occurs to me that you know when i
i get my direct deposits which i love
you know i i have no problem with that
but some folks do um
i can always check my bank account to
see if the money that was supposed to go
in actually did if i get a pay stub
and a uh
a
payment card um how would i know how
much money is actually on that card and
if it matches the stub
sure yeah you would look at the pay stub
as you would a payroll check it has the
net pay amount that was credited to your
account and obviously you can also you
typically use your phone to check your
your you know bank
uh to see you know the amount that i
don't have a bank okay um it's just the
payroll card itself um yeah it comes
with uh an app that tracks your spending
and tracks deposits and things like that
so it's right on your phone
so you can see the amount that's
actually on the card itself at any time
does that make sense sorry i guess
um
so basically my uh my app would know
follow
um
my app
would be able to track exactly how much
money is left on my uh payroll card
yes right so yeah it'll show the deposit
it'll show any spending that you know
your purchase at starbucks it'll give
you a spending uh analysis over the past
month and things like that so it's
actually pretty helpful for just
financial management okay thank you
any further questions
mr clark
um if a person doesn't have a phone how
would they get this information
um that person would probably use that
um you know employer kiosk to print
their paper pay stub or if they don't
have internet access at home or
something like that typically people
have internet access at home and can
look up their pay stub but if they don't
have that they can just use the kiosk at
the employer shop to to print their pay
statement
further questions
representative mavalani
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
iceberg for taking the questions um
if a issue with adp
say you've swept the money out of your
employer's account put it in yours and
there's a hiccup between your
company and the payroll card
would the employer be liable for that
under this
if there's a problem between adp the
payroll company and the card company
somehow resulting in no non-payment
correct or late payment or non-payment
or double payment or
any anything that falls within this
liable for late payment of wages yes the
employer would be reliable and that's
kind of the way the law works today
again as the department of labor
mentioned they really don't have
authority over all the payroll companies
you know in the nation so they wouldn't
be able to directly enforce wage and
error laws against the payroll card
companies or the payroll companies but
the employers responsible and the
payroll card companies and the payroll
companies themselves are liable to the
employer under contract you know so if
there's a problem
the employer sorts it out helps the
employee gets that solved and then goes
after the uh payroll company and says
what was the problem you need to
reimburse me for this
okay
thank you
representative sylvestro
oh no
um
representative cahill actually this
question is for my colleagues who are on
the committee who are employers how many
of you have employee kiosks
go ahead
uh yes
i do
uh comes directly from my payroll
company to myself
and they have access to it
any further questions for uh
yes sir
so
for example for most of the time
when i uh
my payday comes up
i take my card and i go to the bank near
my employer in nashua let's say
and
everything works out fine
one week there's a snowstorm and i live
in either
windham new hampshire or i live in
lowell massachusetts
how would i
could i take my car to a lowell bank
and
how would i do it would i take it to the
cashier or would i put it into the
atm machine to try to get my pay and
would i
have to pay a fee
am i being clear sure
yeah i think so um
basically just how the how this works
you know if you have the card you're in
maybe another state or you're in maybe
there's a snowstorm the the pay is on
your card today so uh if you want to
actually convert that to cash because
you want to use cash for some reason yes
you'd walk up to the any bank teller of
any any bank
that's a visa affiliate or a mastercard
affiliate and just say can you give me
the full value on the card and they give
that
to you in full in cash or you can go to
any atm
and use that atm to get cash
if it's an out of network atm there may
be a fee
for doing that but again we make it
pretty easy to find atms where there's
with better in-network
okay thank you
representative schmidt
thank you mr chairman it just occurred
to me that
your company takes good care of its
people takes care of the people who are
your customers
and i'm pleased to see that
but it's clear that there are some
companies that aren't as
high
in regard do you think it's time to
regulate the industry
to regulate the payroll card industry
um
i
i guess it would be a question you know
if there have been you know serious
abuses that haven't been able to be
resolved
um then you know perhaps i guess i'm not
sure i would be able to comment on that
well you you said it about seven percent
of uh people fall into that and don't
receive yeah um that seven percent is
likely to be the person who is new to
the country who doesn't speak the
language who is unbanked they're the
ones that really really need extra help
with this and could be taken for a ride
um the person that i had referenced to
everybody in an email
she was an intelligent person
worked full-time went to college took
care of her kids and she still fell into
this trap didn't even know enough to
come to the labor department for help
so it would seem to me that maybe there
are
disreputable companies out there that
are giving your industry a very bad name
and perhaps it's time to regulate um but
i did have another question so you you
walk up to an atm
an approved one and this this is not
necessarily you but it could be any of
your your cohorts uh you ask for your
check amount
and there's a small fee on it um so you
take out
30 of it because you need some cash in
hand now when you withdraw some preps
the next week
not not on the same are you drawing from
the previous card and would there be a
charge on that or is every card uh
new or or you're building
an account it's so unclear
thank you
it's a good question thank you for
asking that um
an employee has issued a single payroll
card so that's their payroll card it
represents the payroll card account and
that is functionally equivalent to a
bank account
so the card doesn't change um just
amounts keep getting added to it as over
time the person works and so forth and
as they spend or you know withdraw money
from it it just gets taken out as
with a bank account
does that help
if i may
follow up but but what if you don't take
it all out this week
and another pay period happens and you
take out some that next week are you
charged a fee
oh um i think the the
the law here um guarantees that there is
at least one free transaction per pay
period
uh to take out you know the amount up to
the full amount on the card
beyond that again if you're using outer
network atms then there may be fees
associated with subsequent withdrawals
thank you
representative warden thank you thank
you
the this bill would require that if an
employee loses
or
destroys his or her payroll card that
the employer replaces within 24 hours
how does that work logistically do
employers have a stack of these or they
have to order it through you or through
the bank to have it mailed to the
employee as a replacement
yeah thank you for asking that it's a
challenging issue um and we saw that was
amended in after the senate hearing
um and it is a challenge and essentially
yes we knew we do have to provide all
clients for example with um some
cards ready to go and those are instant
issue cards they don't have names
imprinted on them
so if anybody does have a problem
they've got a card stock and they can
actually just put it into their reader
and print it
communicate with the payroll company and
hand it to the employee
so they're logistically it works then
you know probably a week later the
person gets their imprinted card
replacement card
do i see a hand over here
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for the opportunity
happily turn it back over to the chair
thank you are there any additional
individuals i don't have any pink cards
but i also like to speak
on this bill house bill 209
saying none thank you for closing the
hearing on house bill 209 i'm sorry
brian did you
sure before we open the next hearing uh
mr vice chairman
is this me privately or the golden
committee
okay just a moment
all right i'm going to open the hearing
on house bill 345
regarding youth employment
and i would like to
welcome the green valley school in
pembroke that is paying attention or
listening
on the web so thank you very much
pardon
the vice vice chairman's daughter is uh
one of the students
so he wanted to know that
um when they call senator erin hennessey
to introduce her bill senator thank you
mr chairman and members of the committee
i'm erin hennessey i'm the state senator
for district one which is the northern
half of grafton and all of coast county
i am here to introduce sb 345 which is
relative to youth unemploy youth
employment
um this came out of discussions that i
had with um
mostly they were uh small um
restaurants in in the north country um
during the height of the pandemic time
when they got back into um
serving their clients but didn't have
enough employees and you would walk in
some place and there'd be a 14 year old
hostess there and he or she
wouldn't be able to see you because the
tables weren't cleared and
in our current law that 14 year old
can't clear away empty beer glasses
because of the way our laws are written
so this first section of this bill
deals with clearing up what is kind of
our
probably old and outdated and in my
discussions with various different
departments i don't even think they're
aware of this language in the rsa so
it says that if you're 14 and you're
able to work you can clear
glasses
from a table so it just helps out a lot
of restaurants that are looking for
workers and allows
responsibilities to expand the second
section deals with um 16 and 17 year old
workers only
and it it clears up a lot of confusion
um that i have heard from a lot of
different employers um other than
restaurant owners as well
and it it tries to just clarify how many
hours a
student or a 16 or 17 year old can work
during the week
and doesn't put limitations on if
there's four days of school that week or
three days of school that week
and then finally the third section um
also clears up what i found out to be
the most confusing section of our labor
laws right now and it
um if you look at the way um
rsa 276 a 13 right now related to night
work it says no youth who works more
than two nights a week past 8 p.m or
before 6 a.m shall be permitted to work
more than eight hours in any shift
during the particular week that's a very
confusing
law for not only students to keep track
of their hours but
employees so
the way section 3 is written written
right now helps to clarify that and i'd
be happy to take questions and also
recognize that there's people behind me
that will answer them as well
thank you senator uh mr vice chairman
thank you mr chairman
so
my colleagues that have been with me on
a while on this committee a while won't
be surprised i'm going right to the
night work
so the existing night work law as
obscure as it can be
if i were to boil it down i would say
it's a limitation on overtime on in
certain certain circumstances
the
new version of that law is a hard limit
preventing anyone who's 17 from working
past 10 pm
to me that's a big change
it's a big restriction
um
and i wonder
what is behind driving you know
basically a sledgehammer
it's a it's a big risk restriction on
youth workers and i'm wondering what the
problem that's being addressed in that
besides simply the confusion with the
current law
my understanding is that it's it's a lot
of the confusion um people
often read the law to that no one could
work past eight o'clock at night even
though it doesn't say that um
additionally if you work
past eight o'clock on friday or saturday
night you can't work eight hours
more than eight hours in a shift
so friday and saturday night are not
school nights and kids should be able to
work
longer ships if they were like on
weekends
thank you
thank you mr chairman um
the line four when they're changing it
from 15 to 14 years of age
to clean tables remove empty containers
and glasses
if they're cleaning glasses that have
residual liquor in them
has the liquid commission given a
look at this to make sure that they're
not in possession of alcohol minor in
the possession of alcohol during their
work yes and i apologize if they're not
here today they did submit a letter and
support and i'll make sure that you get
that
yes so they have taken a look at that
and they support this change
and follow up mr chairman
um the
line of
10-11 again with representative seaworth
we worked
quite a bit on this a few years ago um
if a 16 or 17 year old is in a work
study program you know goes to school
one week maybe goes to their
work study or something for following
week are they still only mandated for 35
hours to work that week when they could
be working 40.
if
i think it would depend on how you read
this if if school isn't not in session
for them um because they're working that
week but i i i would
prefer that question somebody else who
would
have the technical knowledge to answer
that i apologize
okay and follow up mr chairman follow up
the night work
let's say a
student wants to work on you know wants
to be a lineman for episodes and
has to work overnight on certain jobs or
is on work release or right now work
study and you know there's a job that is
overnight on a friday night because he's
not in school that's over waking up and
wants to do that this would effectively
tell them they can't do that
yeah thank you for the question uh yes
it would limit their work on a friday
night to 12 a.m and this was not in the
original bill the um senate committee
amended it to
say this
thank you thank you mr chairman
representative of attitude followed by
representative cahill
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
if a student gets out of work
at 3 p.m and they drive to their work
which in a rural area like grafton and
coast county can be upwards of 30
minutes or an hour away
they start their shift at 4 o'clock but
they get out at 10 pm on a school night
they're getting home at about 10 30 10
45 they still get ready for bed our own
southern new hampshire university
suggests that a teenager gets 8 to 10
hours of sleep at night to be functional
in school
so if they meet that they're meeting or
they're sleeping from 11 p.m to 7 a.m
and immediately have to get up and get
ready for school at 8.
at what point during that interval was
the child supposed to do the two hours
of homework that they got to sign that
day in school um thank you for the
question uh i would just say that not
all of our students are alike and not
all of their family situations are alike
and some of our kids do 16 and this is
16 and 17 year olds only do have to go
to work for many different reasons um
and i would also point out that a lot of
our students do co-curricular activities
like my daughter's in drama and she
doesn't get home until 10 o'clock at
night and has to figure out how to do
her um homework as well
follow up follow up
when i listened to this bill's
introduction in the center commerce
committee and correct me if i'm wrong
but it looked like you referenced the
labor shortage as one of the motivators
for the introduction of the bill
and in discussions with this i've heard
well a student doesn't have to work
those 35 hours they can just work up to
that like you said a lot of
circumstances are different
but if employers see this nice new cap
for them to get more hours out of and
they schedule those kids for that do you
see those kids feeling pressure to work
those hours to keep that job instead of
voicing their concerns and saying i need
to pump the brakes on this because i'm
failing my classes because i can't do my
homework
thank you again for the question so the
the current cap is 40 and a half hours
so it's it's actually a higher cap
so it's a it would be a lower cap than
we have in current law
now follow-up
representative cahill
thank you senator for taking my question
i'm looking at lines nine and ten
uh in any employer's predetermined
designated work week during which school
is in session for five days
what happens if it's only in school for
four days if there's a holiday
all bets are off
thank you for the question no that was
what this this portion of the bill tried
to clarify because there was a lot of
confusion
with for for student workers and for uh
employers about the current language and
four days of work four days of school or
five days of school and how many hours
they may work so
um
this attempted to clear that up
follow up
i i appreciate i i i appreciate that
there certainly is confusion but this
leaves it sort of vague in that what
it's it's like the law doesn't apply
if it's if they're not in school for
five days so i'm not sure we've answered
the question
yes thank you for sorry sorry thank you
for that question that is for summer
time um or or or breaks when school is
not in session
then this would not apply you see
thank you
and i apologize mr chair i misstated our
current cap is 48 hours and not 41.5
hours
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question um
with reference to the night work section
do i understand this correctly that um
during summertime
um
where this section would still apply
uh
no youth
would be able to work later than 10
o'clock on
a sunday through thursday
notwithstanding that it's
summer
that is an excellent question and i have
to look
i'd have to look at the um
276 a
12 or whatever is above it just to
confirm that but i will get you that
answer
thank you mr chairman thanks for taking
my question uh
if i'm reading this right
right now
under current law
miners
uh
15 year olds
would not be allowed to work in lounge
areas
but if this goes through
they would be
allowed to work in lounge areas
and not
necessarily to pick up glasses
it just
frees them up to work in lounge areas
thank you for the question it allows 14
and 15 year olds to clean tables remove
empty containers and glasses and assist
in stocking
in those areas
but
you're doing away with this section that
says
15 year olds uh
may be employed in dining areas
and miners
uh
not less than 16 would be
allowed to be employed in lounge areas
would this open up
15 year old
15 year olders to be able to work not
only to pick up glasses but to do other
work in the lounge area thank you for
the question so a lot of
establishments have a dining area and a
lounge area and if they have both then
14 and 15 year olds would be able in
those areas to clean tables remove empty
containers and glasses and assist in
stocking
i hope that answers your question and i
don't know what other activities you
think they would be able to do in a
lounge area
follow up
what other areas that 15 year olds were
not allowed to do in lounge areas before
it had to be 16 year olds that wipes
that out
this it just pertains to what is written
there is miners not less than 14 years
of age may be employed to clean tables
remove empty containers and glasses and
assist in stocking
yeah
i sorry i don't understand your question
are you trying to find out whether or
not they'd be able to serve alcohol or
not is that where your question is going
well uh
16 year olds were not allowed to
deal with alcohol but
they were
allowed to do something that 15 year
olds weren't allowed to do under current
law that's the way i read it
has that
has there been a change
for 15 year olds
senator you're welcome to answer if you
can if you
or not
so this doesn't open up
16 year olds to do anything else that
they weren't allowed to do before and it
doesn't open
up anything that 14 and 15 year olds
weren't allowed to do before other than
to clean tables remove empty
containers and glasses and assist in
stocking
okay thank you
there's an avalanche followed by agent
thank you mr chairman just for
clarification with 16 year olds may be
employed in lounge areas they're
lowering that to 14 years old and taking
out the ability
um to make sure that they're not allowed
to serve and that's why i asked the
question early to make sure that the 14
year olds would be able to be in
possession of
classes that we have residual liquor in
them and things like that when they were
cleaning those tables
thank you for the question yes they
would be able to clear empty glassware
or
residual
beverages and be allowed in lounge areas
correct thank you representative
followed by proud
thank you mr chairman um if the main
crux
of the bill is to eliminate some of the
confusing language
and
allow for
minors to clear glasses off the tables
would there be resistance to the
forthcoming amendment
that would move
the maximum hours that a student is
allowed to work
when
school is in session five days a week to
24 hours
and set the maximum amount of time or
the maximum hour that they were able to
work on a school night to 8 p.m to
better ensure that that child is able to
get more sleep
do their chores do their homework and be
better prepared for school the following
day
thank you for the question i think there
would be resistance i don't think every
kid even though school may be in session
five days a week has the same school
calendar
some of our students have half days of
school and go to work full-time or 35
hours a week or what have you
um
so i think every individual for 16 and
17 year old their situation is different
and like i said
we don't resist the uh restrict the
amount of hours on our kids that do
co-curricular activities
and so if they're not doing those and
they're choosing to work instead i don't
think a lower amount of hours is
relevant
i understand your point about
co-curricular activities um are you
aware of co-curricular activities that
um take up to 35 hours a week
um while school is in session
yes
especially if you're on more than one
team and
and a band
or a math team
representative proud
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question um regarding the
night work section uh comparing it to
what it replaced what it replaced said
that it applies until 6am
and the new language doesn't have that
so it's unclear to me
whether someone would have to clock out
at midnight and clock back in at 12 15
or if they have to wait till dawn or
what the intent is there
yes
no i don't know
that's a very good question
so apparently this is still confusing
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
um again so the uh back to night work on
line 21 what if there's a holiday on
monday
they wouldn't be able to work sunday
night into monday to midnight
like memorial day weekends very heavy up
north
july 4th weekends labor day weekends
columbus day weekends
they would be limited on that sunday
even though they have no school on
monday
yes you're correct thank you
thank you
see no other
hands no other questions thank you very
much senator thank you mr chairman i'll
get you the letter from the liquor
commission thank you
commissioner ogden
the department of labor
good afternoon thank you representative
infantine um just in terms of uh to be
clear weak the department of labor can't
speak to the first portion as was
referenced by the senator that would be
the liquor commission who would or
should or could speak to that in terms
of section two the two things we just
wanted to point out
was in addition to raising the cap of 30
hours to 35 it's also eliminating the
more than six consecutive days and i
just want to be clear on that because
we had not seen or spoken to this
amendment this amendment was made after
the the public hearing at senate uh so
we just want to be very clear that in
addition to raising the cap during a
week from 30 to 35 hours
it's also
raising the idea that individuals could
work seven days consecutively or these
youth could work seven days
consecutively
representatives are some
responsive to some of the concerns that
representative adjudant had brought up
the most calls that we get on youth
labor for uh
night work is the idea that people don't
believe that their children should be
working past a certain hour that's
always been a problem in my opinion
humble opinion relative to the existing
law is the existing law of night work it
does set inside this limitation that if
an individual youth was to work past
eight o'clock there would then be
ramifications that the employer would
have to keep track of and i do think to
the senator's point that has led some
employers in practice to just say i'm
not going to have a kid work past eight
but to be clear present law would allow
a kid to work entirely through the night
and that has been the bulk of the calls
that we get on night work is parents
calling us and saying my kid's working
at 11 o'clock that's not
allowed right and it is allowed um so i
just want to be clear that that that's
really uh the calls that we get on night
work i can't speak to um i had heard
about the
sledgehammer or hard
i can't speak to how restrictive this
would be to certain employers i don't
know how they do their staffing
but i'm happy to answer any questions if
folks have questions relative to the
legislation
thank you mr chairman um
again section 8 9 10 11 from the
30 to 35 hours in the six executive days
if child if the student is enrolled in a
work study program they go to school one
week and they're on their job the next
week
do you see a problem with this being
changed for
for that
working six context working six
executive days or 40 hours per week
how we would presently apply that is
would we
presently apply it if it's if school is
in session or if there's a vacation week
that's where we wouldn't look at the
internship or externship type of
environment as not being in school so
therefore the hours
are are elevated so i mean if that's
something that the committee wants to
consider they certainly could uh but
presently we would look at the situation
you're talking about is that if the kid
if it's not a vacation week the the kid
is in school so the hour limitations
would apply representative cahill and i
apologize that reminds me of the
question that representative cahill
brought up i do think that that is
something to consider that as presently
drafted where it says school is in
session for five days if school was not
in session for five days you would not
have the 35 hour cap you would instead
default to the cap which says 48 hours
and that's in 276 a11 which says
notwithstanding the pres any of the
provisions in a4
you have a hard cap at 48 hours so we
would look at a4 and we would say okay
school was in session school was not in
session for five days therefore the 35
hours doesn't apply
and then you would default to 276 a11
which would be the uh 48 hours
the only other thing i apologize that i
would offer
is that in terms of the uh i can echo
the center senator sentiments that
individual employers have contacted us
and saying the sliding scale that was
introduced in 2018 was difficult to work
with the sliding scale being that if
school was in session for four days they
could do 40 and a quarter if it was
three or less they could do 48 employers
typically told us they did not leverage
the flexibility provided by that because
it was difficult for them to account for
how many days was the kid in school on a
given
work week or pay period
you gotta finish up with episode avalani
follow up
okay representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman
um
so
my first question was related to that
section we were just discussing on line
11.
um to me
this language about the six consecutive
days limit which is being
repealed isn't that redundant with the
day of rest
legislation which applies universally
not just to
teens
in other words
if if an employer was trying to employ a
teenager during the school year
for seven days
in a week
doesn't that
fall under the day of rest
section of our rsas
yes i do i see your point i do think
that that could present as a a
prohibition on that type of staffing
thank you
and my follow-up which is
um not quite related
going to the night work you mentioned
that most of the problems
had to deal with confusion people
thinking maybe the law prohibited things
that it doesn't or the other way the
employer not understanding what the
prohibition means to them
are there situations
and how common are they where the law is
presumably intended is the issue
that in other words employers who are
pushing the limit with
after hours and overtime that
the real issue is
too long shifts running too late at
night or would you say
that almost entirely the issue is
confusion with the law and people
wondering why it hasn't put a limit on
the hours
i think it's the latter i think that the
when we talk about night work or we try
and explain
why there could or should be something
such as night work i think the real
concern is what representative adjudant
brought up this idea that
people or kids in school should be
having enough rest to be able to show up
to school the next day and perform and i
think the existing law has been
confusing to that because again you
could have kids work all night every
night so long as they're not working
shifts longer than eight hours
so that's always been something that i
think rang is a little confusing to
folks because they were saying how is
this preventing the problem and again i
think in a general sense the problem
being people think that youth should be
going home going to bed and being able
to wake up to go to school the next day
well
thank you you got to move this along yes
so i want to echo it was an earlier
question
to your understanding though the night
work section is not related to school
being in session it's a general
prohibition based on age so it applies
equally during the summer as it would
during the school
that's year
yes thank you
and just the last thing i would say is i
am going to confirm i'm going to look at
that day of rest issue and i'll respond
to the committee i just want to make
sure i'm not misstating that i'll look
at the day of rest whether that serves
the same purpose as the six consecutive
days news about lenny
uh thank you mr chairman thank you
deputy commissioner um
striking out sections b and c how would
that affect homeschoolers
homeschoolers in terms of our
application a lot of homeschoolers has
been that if the district in which they
reside is in session we consider them to
be in session
i any additional questions
representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
ogden
um i agree that it's been very confusing
and we haven't helped matters much with
our most recent effort
okay
thank you
uh yeah i i think the confusion is was
made worse in our last effort and this
doesn't help a lot either
i i think there should be a bright line
at perhaps nine o'clock on school nights
instead of ten
and uh would it be possible would it be
sensible to say that this
uh own that little supply during the
school year
so if somebody has um
a holiday they could do a little bit
more work around the house or get ready
for that s.a.t
uh whatever they're just having it's
during the school year you can't work
past nine o'clock on a week night
or
i'm not i'm fine with midnight on or if
you don't have school but during the
school year
which is
september or august through
june would that be easier to understand
because i think many of your
incidents you find out after the fact
that the error the violation has
occurred
i i understand your point representative
i do think that that is a policy
decision in terms of if you think it
should be specifically stated towards
school i do think that that comes up and
that the employers are looking for
flexibility on those uh summer vacations
on those weeks in which there's vacation
so i think it's a sensible thing to work
on and look to but it's ultimately a
policy decision thank you
thank you mr chairman following up with
representative cahill if we make it for
the school year
sometimes juniors and seniors do get out
a little earlier than the rest of the
segment
would they be held to
that school year even though they are
technically out of school i think we
would still look are they duly enrolled
in terms of if they've not graduated yet
or separated yet i don't know i i'll be
honest in saying i don't know how we've
dealt with that issue even currently in
terms of looking at that summer slide
type of scenario i don't i don't i don't
know how we've dealt with that but i
think we're looking are they duly
enrolled duly enrolled in school and is
school in session in the particular
district thank you
thank you um
you mentioned
the
getting calls from parents at say like
you know my child is working until 11 pm
is as legal as this allowed
is there ever any follow-up to those
discussions uh where the parent says
something like
um i don't want my child to lose their
job
uh if they complain to the manager that
they're not getting their homework done
or they're incapable of meeting other
responsibilities because that's one of
the pressure points that i see on this
is
students feeling like they don't want to
lose that job
and don't want to like upset things at
home
but also
and as a consequence of that not telling
the employer i can't work until 10 pm at
night because i'm failing my classes
thank you for the i think it's a great
question because it's actually a large
part of the dialogue in those contexts
is because you'd say you think you'd say
to the parent well don't let them work
but the parents will often say to us
well if i
tell my kid they
can't do it they'll just replace them
with someone who can do it so it's kind
of
that's the concern so you're spot on
that that is the issue is that parents
are seeing it as if uh they set the the
barrier their kid might lose their job
or uh those hour you know so that is the
concern
and
in thank you um and in an instance where
maybe you have a more
maybe you have a parent who says well my
child can handle that you know it they
can toughen up or they can figure out
how to do their homework maybe they can
do it in study hall that's one that i
have personal experience with
um
is that then putting that 16 year old in
the position of having to go to the
employer where there's that power
imbalance and say
i need to be let out earlier than
everybody else
at night which may make that student
uncomfortable or pressure them to not in
fact ask the employer that
i could see that as being possible
so you know further questions thank you
very much
i have one of these buttons up here
where i can turn or turn everybody off
if someone gets out of hand that's what
i did accidentally mike
uh
the next card mike silland
from aroma joe's
sorry mr summers you gotta wait one more
turn
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
the committee for
accepting and receiving me here today my
name is mike sullen i represent aroma
joe's coffee
it was started
22 years ago our first store was in east
rochester new hampshire
we've grown to 83 stores across six
states uh 34 of those
um 83 are in new hampshire and we're
quite we're quite proud of that um
it was a business started by my brother
and myself and my two cousins um four of
us
um
we
the majority of our staff and if any of
you are customers probably know they're
all high school and college kids this is
their first job we have a high turnover
rate but we're proud of that
these are kids that come to us and it's
they've never answered a phone
not knowing who was not on the other
side of it they do not know how to clean
a toilet they don't know how to sweep or
mop a floor this isn't everyone that i'm
talking about i'm giving you
real examples though um five to ten
percent of these kids
don't know how to wash dishes with hot
water
um
and i want to make sure that the
committee understands that
we value them we value their education i
come from a family of educators um my
two daughters
worked for my company my youngest one
still does um and i'm quite proud of the
life skills that she's learned she knows
what a gfci outlet is she knows how to
fix it when it's tripped she knows how
to turn the water off if the sink is
leaking
um these are real solid life skills they
know how to count change back
um you ask a kid today that you know
doesn't
hasn't worked in this kind of industry
they may not know how to make change
so i think it's important to remember
that
um i'm here today not representing what
this
not supporting this bill for what it can
do for me as an employer
i'm here to explain what an employer
like myself means to the state of new
hampshire
in the 22 years that we've been
operating in the state we we must have
employed tens of thousands of young kids
that we send out into the world with
these life skills
and
from some of the things that i've heard
today absolutely uh you know
we we don't require we're not we're not
pressuring these kids to work
into the night or longer hours we are
trying to make it available to them if
they so choose
to make that decision
with their educators with their teachers
their principals their families we're
trying to let the choice be theirs but
the way that the law cert the currently
is written
very confusing very limiting
and i'll give an example and because
i've heard you know extracurricular
activities and and you know what do
those hours mean you know we had a young
gentleman um
didn't want me to use his name here
today but he was in a band a a real
instrumental band he was a guitar player
he was a great student
but
pulled good grades was 16 years old had
his parents permission but he he wanted
he wanted to work because he had to put
himself through school he he was going
to be the one responsible to earn his
way through college he had his own car
payment he had his own gas to put in and
he certainly made a little bit of money
playing with this ban but not a lot
um and he
he with the with the law currently
written
i couldn't give him the hours without
going into violation i couldn't let him
work the hours that he wanted to work
without going into violation
and he ended up just getting another job
so in the instance where we're concerned
about me
you know
leveraging or or or threatening someone
to lose their job because they can't
fulfill it's the absolute opposite
i'm here today to answer any questions
that i can about my business and how
this law affects what i do
um but it's i think it's real important
that you guys that everyone here
understands that for aroma joes at least
this is um a a real opportunity to
continue doing what we're doing for
these for these kids and in since that
um night work sliding scale very very
confusing and honestly it it's not worth
trying to track
the difficulty that that is
with the way that it's that the way it's
currently right
thank you members of addition followed
by sullivan
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question um
what
what would be the drop-off in picked up
skills
that one of your student employees could
pick up
in 24 hours a week versus 35 hours a
week is there a measurable difference
there yep um thank you for your question
no there no there's not a measurable
difference but i can give you an example
of
out of the
300 employees that i currently have
control over in the state that's only 13
of those 34 stores are mine so there's
going to be a over a thousand
instances
where i can't quantify that for you but
i can tell you the 300 employees that i
have the average 16 or 17 year old hours
worked for me
is 16 hours a week i'm not going to get
anywhere near
the 35 hour cap
but
there are going to be some instances
like the band member that i just gave
you where he
went and worked somewhere else kept his
kept a job
he left me completely then he just chose
to work two part-time jobs somewhere
else and i'm saying well he wanted to
stay with us i wanted to employ him but
i couldn't so he just chose to left and
then worked two part-time jobs somewhere
else follow up follow up thank you um to
paraphrase an earlier conversation uh
during a different hearing
would you believe that there are
employers in the state of new hampshire
who are not as
considerate as far as staying away from
the cap and making sure that their
employees
don't feel that kind of pressure that a
place like aroma joes would be
sure i believe that that's possible um i
don't know of any um nor would i want to
take a stab at a guess at any but
certainly i believe that's possible i
believe that that's probably more
possible with companies that have
a
eight hour shifts we we don't do that
specific to the labor pool that we have
and we're lucky i get a whole flood of
new people every year but the back end
of that the unlucky part of that is they
leave
a year and a half two and a half years
after they start so
for me
you know
i don't have
i don't have specific
you know
information that i can answer that says
yeah those people do it but we don't i
don't know that but i for but for us our
longest shifts are four hours
and that's why i don't approach
that 35 hour cap i support the 35-hour
cap because there are instances where
that would have helped me retain an
individual that wanted to stay working
for me but i couldn't without going into
violation
representative sullivan
thank you for taking my question um
the um
you mentioned the band member um and the
fact that you would have been in
violation if you had
um
done what he
he wanted to do
could you specifically exactly what the
violation would have been and what
exactly what he wanted you to do yep he
sure so he was under 18 and he wanted to
work later at night we closed at 9 00
p.m
so i couldn't
employ him past 8 p.m
so and he wanted more than the allowable
hours during that sliding scale week so
if school was in session for
five days a week he was only allowed to
work
those those hours into the night but i
didn't want to deal with any of that
because of the confusion and because of
tracking this one individual would have
just taken more resources that it was
that it's worked than what it would have
been worth but i felt bad for
for him
because i didn't want to keep track of
of how difficult it would be currently
to keep track of
follow up
so what exactly would be the violation
that you would have uh he would have
gone go sorry yeah thank you for your
question he would have he would have
he
would i would have wanted him to work
more than eight hours
following a night that he would have
worked past 8 p.m
and and all that work for one individual
i just don't have the resources for that
by sharing
thank you very much mr chairman i want
to follow up on that one and i i think i
understand the concern with the current
night work
but as a substitute
where
there would be proposed a
a lim a hard limit on start time a hard
limit on end time
it
would that be a viable solution to you
if those times did not match your
business hours either if they couldn't
start when your store opened or they
couldn't work past the time when your
store closed sure thank you for your
question right now the way that the re
the bill has been introduced it does fit
with with what i
w
with what works for me so i guess i
would need a scenario to answer
specifically
and if i may follow up i'm
i apologize i'm kind of asking you to
project to employers who aren't here for
example a farmer who might employ
someone pretty early in the morning
or
i don't know what time mcdonald's closes
i haven't been to one in a while or some
places sure a place that's open till 11
or open until midnight where it would
clearly
fall outside of this um
it all
my question is
unless
your business happens to fit the model
and the bill isn't the cure worse than
the
than the problem
if you find yourselves
find yourself in a situation where
you're unable to employ people in your
business hours because of the change in
law sure so thank you for the follow-up
and i'll try the best i can to answer
that the way that i understand that
you've asked it
so
for me in my experience with just what i
do i would say that this wouldn't a
farmer would love this
an individual that happens to not have
to go to school because we all
understand school is much different than
when we were all there you had to be
there at 7 30 you left at 2 30. done
that was that was easy for them that is
not the way it is now right so for me if
a farmer could have an individual that
doesn't have to be in school for any for
that one particular day let's just say
that this individual student has enough
credits or they have a work release day
that day i would think that the farmer
would love it that that person could
show up at three a.m
and work an eight-hour shift or a
10-hour shift and not be restricted now
that may not work for a restaurant that
is open to 11 p.m
hey honestly i don't like the 10 p.m cut
off date i i think it should be later
but
but in the spirit of what the the other
um committee members said i do believe
that kids should get rest and should be
prepared for the next day
the issue that i have currently is
they have to they're leaving at 8 00 p.m
but they're not going home
to to study and do homework they're
driving to their friend's house and
playing video games or that like and i'm
not trying to i'm not trying to fix the
the state of our youth i'm trying to
employ the ones that want more hours and
that want to do this job and i truly
believe that companies like mine are
doing
right by the state
by teaching these kids these life skills
all right representative
greg
sorry
thank you chairman um i just want to
take a quick second i apologize to the
chair this is not a question i just want
to say thank you
very well
any uh any additional questions
representing
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony today and taking our questions
um it's been said that
parents have complained to dol that
their child's working longer than they
should be um have you read interactions
with parents where they come in to you
and say hey you know can you give them
less hours or if this job is interfering
can you adjust their hours or anything
like that if you had that type of
interaction when there's been a problem
because they're working
not too many hours but because they're
working an extra job outside of their
regular curriculum
sure yep yeah thank you for your
question yeah we have and and um and we
deal with that um like we deal with any
situation with any interaction with a
parent customer vendor or an employee
that absolutely we ask what's the
problem what what's going on their their
grades are slipping absolutely no
problem we are a completely open and um
very transparent company with our
employees we tend to not try to deal
with the parents too much because we
don't employ the parents but if there's
a real issue
i would hope that they would feel
comfortable reaching out to me before
calling the new new hampshire department
of labor but if they if if they did and
it became an issue absolutely it's not
more important to me that i have a 16
year old kid working
from seven to nine
it's more important that that kid's got
a good home life and he's got in and
they've got good grades and they're
generally
happy in their life this isn't about me
just covering a two-hour shift it's i
truly believe
if more people did what we did and cared
for these kids
that is ultimately what's better for me
as a business if i have happy productive
employees then i'm going to have a very
successful business so i'm not trying to
create an environment where i'm
forcing kids to work i i just want to
create an environment where if they want
to and in some cases they need their
parents permission
then absolutely i would like them to
work for me because i think we're doing
great things for them and i'm and i'm
speaking
for my employees they want more hours
than i can currently give them
susie
thank you mr chairman um this is going
to be would you believe
because i agree with everything you say
because i personally have a daughter
that actually works for your company
here in concord
and they've been very supportive
academically she's fantastic sports-wise
she's a great athlete um but when she
asks for time off or when she asks for
time to work
that company that you own has been very
supportive and we appreciate that so
thank you thank you
so i actu i actually do believe that and
thank you
i mean i would hope we were doing
something right all this all this time
so see no other questions thank you very
much for your testimony appreciate that
last card i have mike summers new
hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
mike summers i'm the president ceo of
new hampshire lodging and restaurant
association we're here in support of sb
345.
i think you've kind of hashed this to
death i don't know that i have much to
add to that so
um a couple things uh i will add is you
know there was some discussion in the
senate hearing around night work and
obviously night work has been
hugely problematic for our industry uh
it's confusing many people were in
violation of it um simply because you
know
if a
student worked uh to 8 30 on tuesday and
wednesday and then tried to put in a
nine or a ten hour shift on saturday or
sunday or you know friday night they
were automatically in violation it was
extremely confusing and as the previous
speaker said most businesses just stayed
away from it because they didn't
understand it didn't know how to manage
it and frankly it wasn't worth the time
and effort so um you know i think
originally when senator hennessey filed
this bill she actually just struck the
whole night work section which was what
we had testified in support of and
preferred um but i think that there was
also some uh discussion in that
committee hearing much like you're
having here about you know what should
sometimes be and i will concur with uh
the statement made earlier that you know
10 p.m uh outside of this the school
year for um you know
middle of the summer for student on a
saturday night is problematic for our
industry i'll be perfectly honest with
you so um
hopefully you know ultimately we'd love
to see it struck
but if that can't be the case and
obviously we'd like the bright line to
be as late as it can be because again
our industry flexibility is going to be
key for for most of our businesses
i don't know that i need to really speak
to lounge um but
i guess i'll end with that the one thing
i will say is i guess the
existing lines 12 through 17
again change made in 2018
hugely confusing for businesses no
businesses took advantage of this to my
knowledge and frankly it ended up being
more of a headache than anything else so
we're actually happy to see that go away
um and try to come to some other kind of
an arrangement so
with that i will end and i'm happy to
attempt to answer any questions mr
summers um i believe
if
in the senate unless i'm
totally missed something here um senator
soucy wanted the ten o'clock um
uh again and that was a compromise that
was made is that i believe that is the
case yes but i also don't want to speak
for senator susie but i believe that was
the case okay
any other questions mr summers it was
amendable
thank you mr jim um
no more i i'm asking you to speak for
your
um your organization if you feel
comfortable doing that uh if
the uh
night work section instead of what it
said
um provided that uh no person of
the age uh governed
could work past
say either eight or nine o'clock p.m on
a night before school was in session and
said nothing else would your
organization be able to support that
as with all legislative language i'd
love to see that in writing first um but
i think that again i think that
with the language you see there on lines
2021 i think that was just an
accommodation to try to get to some
kind of a compromise i guess um i don't
know that i could say definitively that
we would support that i would want to
see the see it in writing but ultimately
i think that there is some recognition
from industry and from business owners
that yes we don't necessarily want our
kids work until one in the morning every
school night either so um
one thing i will add is
i'm not sure if you're aware but there's
a workforce shortage right now and
pretty much uh our workers are setting
the standards so when somebody asks us
for time off or they can't work past an
hour uh businesses are accommodating it
they're falling all over themselves to
accommodate it because if we don't there
are four other businesses within the
same city block that will be happy to
accommodate that so it is a very much a
workers environment right now and we
couldn't be more accommodating
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
summers um the 12 o'clock on friday and
saturday night um
given
pouring establishments should typically
stay open later than that would
would you like to see that struck and to
representative mandeville's was
and just have a to 8 p.m on as long as
there was a previous next day of school
that would eliminate the holiday issues
that we spoke about earlier and vacation
weeks
well and i think
part of the well
part of the clunky part of night work
was this whole um days when school is in
session is the way it's currently
drafted and the real issue with that is
sunday was not considered considered a
school day even though they had school
you know first thing monday morning
but they couldn't work later on fridays
because it was a school day so the
existing structure didn't really work
either so so
but to your question um
yeah i i frankly we would love to see
night work just go away it has been
nothing but a headache for for industry
um but if we were to do something
um again i think we should focus it
around when school is in session uh
because i think there's a there's a
recognition there um i don't know about
eight or nine o'clock and again i will
go back to my early statement i want to
see it in writing before i make any
commitments
all right
so you know other hands thank you very
much thank you mr summers i don't have
any other pink cards or anyone else like
to speak
so yeah i'm closing the hearing on uh
senate bill 345.
um
is this a natural reaction i turn to the
right i guess i i have a question of the
committee
um we have a situation with house senate
bill 276 that we heard first thing this
morning we have a bill in front of us
that's relatively simple and we have an
amendment
um
this was thrown at me this week just
like you know you guys when i sent it to
you last night that was the first i had
received the the official amendment that
i sent it on
we have two situations here we can wait
till next wednesday if we want to exact
this
if we execute um today
we will
and pass it on to finance
we are technically within it has to be
out of committee today
if not i don't know what the speaker's
going to do about suspending rules
because it's not
because it
bills have to go to second committee
have to be done today
so i'm in a between a rock and a hard
place here because i have a lot of
members not here and i don't know how
people are going to vote
i
chairman personally thinks that um
our lane has to do with the original
bill
um the finance part isn't in our lane
and i'd rather chuck it over to the
people that do
but because i don't know i haven't had a
caucus i don't know who's going to do
anything i don't want to
cut my nose off to spite my face here
and have this thing die
so um is there a
big group of people that wants this
thing to die could let me know now so i
wait until next wednesday to exact this
mr chairman talk about the amendment or
the underlying bill uh the amendment
if the underlying bill i don't think
daniel has a problem with correct
so it's underlying bills yeah there's
personally i'm not going to support the
amendment the million-dollar spend
yes
yeah anyone could
adopt that amendment
representative proud uh just question of
the
the chairman um
is the deadline tomorrow at noon for two
committee bills
or to today for two community
then bills
representative um part of the calendar
today is the last date to report out
bills that would go to a second
committee and that's usually at noon
so i think we've already i don't know
what reporting out means well i
my understanding is that means we've
already missed the deadline and the
house clerk has directed to put it on
the calendar as no recommendation am i
wrong on that
no that
i don't know the answer if i may yes and
i'm going by the testimony of which
might have been before you came in the
testimony of some of the presenters on
this bill
um the statement was made that the
speaker has been made aware that the
chair of finance has been made aware of
what we're doing so they are ready
if if we should get the even though
we've we've missed the deadline and i
actually talked to heather too about
this
so that everyone knows what we're
thinking of doing
and that
even though we've missed noon already um
they should be ready for our action
should we decide to take it
fine
let's do it
okay
so i'm going to open an executive
session on 276 at my own peril
is there a motion on the floor on the
amendment on the house bill 276
representative seaworth
i'd like to make a motion that
otp with the amendment
yes so
i'll move the amendment
we're going to move amendment 2022-1489
s could you repeat that yes
2 2 0 2 2
1 4 8 9 s
okay
it's been moved by brian uh seaworth
seconded by representative sullivan
you're uh recognized to speak to motion
uh thank you very much mr chairman and
i'll echo what uh both
you have said mr chairman and what my
namesake across the aisle has said
um this amendment is something that
really needs to go to finance and
you know i like some of my colleagues i
i have my own opinion on this
but i think we'd be doing a disservice
if we
try to handle a finance issue here in
labor committee
and so prevent this bill from moving
forward
so
in that
vein
i've made the motion to pass the
amendment
whatever i feel about it
as a means to get this to the correct
committee within the deadline
also comment it it may be a little off
the amendment likewise i think the
underlying bill probably should have
gone to ways and means because that's
who's impacted by the change
not it's not a labor issue in terms of
the changes made but
that's neither here nor there
arizona sullivan
thank you mr chairman
um
i agree with everything that brian said
um i also uh recall what uh
representative almi indicated that um
uh
the money is
in existence now it might not be later
um
and um and i know also know that finance
is loath to um
pass
these kinds of things
in an off-budget year so um
it'll be up to them to decide if they
want to break with that
that habit
um but again i think it's a finance
issue um
and uh
again as i said before it's bizarre that
we got either the bill or the amendment
um just doesn't fit but we i think we
need to move it along so that it can be
addressed where it needs to be addressed
thank you
i wouldn't want anyone messing with a
labor bill in commerce or in municipal
government so i think we are obligated
to pass this on to the people that
will deal with it and then if you don't
like it you can vote against on the
floor
um any other additional comments
seeing none mr clerk the emotion on the
floor
is ought to pass on the amendment um
2022-1489s would you please call the
roll
is the vote right now on the amendment
or the bill the amendment okay it just
sounded like it was both
uh myself yes
love not here
warden
no
haircut i'm not here
um proud
no
boyd no
huff
no
sullivan yes
susie yes
rudy
all right cahill
lisa vestro
schmidt
i guess she left oh she left okay sorry
uh toomey
bouchard yes
headset yes mandible yes
yes
emotions passed and open to further
amendment representative seaworth
i'd like to make the motion ought to
pass as amended
second by uh representative uh
linda
um your emotions on the floor and
seconded
it was uh 12 4.
i don't think i have more much more to
add i'd urge my colleagues to pass this
along and get it to finance where it can
be dealt with appropriately
representative estrogen sullivan
okay the motion on the floor is ought to
pass as amended mr clerk please call the
role seaworth yes
avalani
callum not here
yourself yes love not here or
warden no
no
boyd no
off
no
sullivan yes
susie yes rudy
i'm not here sorry uh cahill yes
uh diesel vestro
toomey
richard yes
edgerton
yes
yes infantine yes
12 to 4 again motion passes 12 to 4.
is there any other uh business in front
of this committee
mr chairman
mr
thank you um i
just want one quick second to pass this
around
representative adagen is proposing an
amendment to uh one of the bills that
was her uh
that we heard today
and um
you can uh discuss it with him um
out of committee
um
if you'd like
i will make sure it gets to everyone
who's not here sure
this has to do with one of the bills
that we um
passed the committee and died on the
floor has to do with uh
productivity quotas
so
one minute josh yep
uh thank you mr chairman members of the
committee uh this is
the language from
hb 1076.
um
this amendment seeks to
add that language to sb 209
per precedent
it is amending the same section of the
rsa
so
uh that has that continuity there
um i
appreciated the across the aisle work
that we were able to do on the original
bill
um
so this is an amendment that i hope to
move forward with next week i will be
speaking with the senate sponsors
uh to see if they have any concerns
um provided it gets to a committee of
conference and passes on the floor
uh so that's where this is at
um if anybody has any questions um i'm
happy to answer those we didn't have a
super long debate on this in the
executive session the entire debate was
myself thanking the chairman for the
good faith negotiations that we did on
that bill so
i'm hoping that this will have
um some good compromise in the final
uh
passage of 209 in the committee um and
that's what i have so
there are a lot of great comments great
questions today you've talked about a
number of things if you'd like to amend
uh ols is really busy so if you're going
to do something
uh try to get it to them very quickly so
it'll be available for all of us to see
before wednesday's executive session
mr vice chairman you have anything from
the committee
any other committee members have any uh
comments of the chair
seeing none thank you very much for
coming today guys
and ladies
you
you will come to find mr chairman that
simply saying a democratic senator
supporting something is not enough
during my interest especially with these
democratic senators
all right
so
you